Yay!
Oh, and...
Why do you laugh?
Why are you laughing?
You're such a larper!
I'm an actual maid, what are you talking about?
Oh wait, oh shit, shit, shit, sorry, I didn't hear you.
I forgot to reroute you in the...
Oh my god.
Oh, but I thought I could keep you separate from the game audio, but I won't be able to.
I think, okay, I'm gonna help you with your settings.
Yeah, no, no, no, I know I can do two desktop audios, yeah!
No, you don't need two desktop audios!
Oh, I guess I could do game audio, right?
Maybe.
I did!
So I have streaming on 3.4, and then I have Discord voice on 5.6.
What the fuck are you talking about?
What do you mean?
But what do you mean you have streaming on 3.4?
Streaming is its own channel.
I know!
I have it on 3.4 so that they can hear my desktop.
And then I... Oh wait, I forgot to turn that on.
And then I have you on 5.6.
Okay, well, I don't know what... The moment I switched scenes my brain turned off.
I used to be smarter.
I used to be taller.
I used to be a baller.
Why are you so obsessed with Erin?
I was really just thinking, man, I wish I was taller.
And then I played the song like 20 times.
And listened to it now forever.
What is that song?
Yeah, what is that?
The baller of all balls doesn't know the song?
What is that?
You were quite sophisticated with your knowledge in songs.
I don't...
I thought.
Maybe not.
All I know... I'm a weeaboo.
All I know is Japanese songs.
But no!
You know all these songs that are, you know, important and cultural.
Do you know... Okay, so here it goes.
It's a rap song.
It goes like...
I wish I was taller.
I wish I was a baller.
I wish I had a girl that was...
What was she?
Cute?
I don't know.
I wish I had a girl...
It's not in a minute.
No, I wish I had a girl that was, whatever, cute for example.
She's rewriting history, guys.
This is new lyrics.
Ah, there it is.
I wish I was...
I wish I was taller.
I wish I was a baller.
I wish I had a girl who would look good.
I would call her...
I wish I had a rabbit with a hat.
No!
I wish I had a rabbit with a hat and...
Someone should put this over the karaoke.
No, it's pretty accurate.
I wish I was... I wish I was a little bit taller.
I wish I was a baller.
I wish I had a girl who looked good.
I would call her...
I wish I had a rabbit in a hat with a bat and a six-form baller.
What does that mean?
Doesn't that... That goes hard!
It's good!
It's really... How do you not know?
I don't know.
Wait, it's an old song?
It's from like 1995?
Yeah, so what?
Don't you know any other songs from before you were born?
I mean, you?
I'm just saying, it's pretty old.
Grandma music over here.
Surely, you know...
Like, what about... I don't know.
What else is from 1995?
Like, surely there's Michael Jackson songs that you know that are from that time.
Or Elvis or Beatles.
Elvis from 1995.
Is that unrealistic?
Don't just laugh at me!
You guys, she's a phoenix.
She doesn't think about any concept of time.
It's confusing.
Okay, maybe he's from like the 70s or... What?
80s?
I think he died in the 70s.
Well, he was probably in his prime, was he not?
He didn't get very old, did he?
He... I wouldn't say prime.
He was... But I think like the 60s was like his prime, right?
50s?
60s?
What are we talking about?
I'm already feeling hot, girl.
Put on some clothes.
I don't know what you're wearing right now, but...
Says you.
I have a dress on.
You have nothing.
You have a logo on your body.
I have a logo on my body?
In the thumbnail.
It's just the logo.
Oh, I thought my boogie tag had a logo on it.
No, you're sitting in my lap.
The logo on my body is just so people would panic less.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
The picture itself is not that... You know, there's nothing to hide.
Right.
I've got nothing to hide.
I'm surprised you weren't... that you didn't like jump on to that art first for your thumbnail.
Did you forget about it already?
I don't think of the spicy thumbnails.
What?!
That's your brain.
No, okay.
Maybe you don't make your thumbnails spicy, but...
M'lady.
No frill, m'lady.
No back of dress, m'lady.
You gave the meaning of a backless dress a new meaning.
A new meaning?
When are we getting the Kiwawa version?
It's difficult.
I think that's a thing only indies can do.
I can't really...
You have your workout outfit.
I think that's...
The KFP don't need... They will have blood loss and they won't be able to work.
I mean, I have my... I can get my 3D model pretty naked, but my 2D model I cannot get naked at all.
What do you mean you can get your 3D model pretty naked?
So you could do it in 3D!
Yeah, which would be worse.
Just don't turn around!
Very difficult.
Even for you in 2D it was already risky.
No, I checked.
It was fine.
Well, next time I hope you can upgrade the dress to a...
Or maybe not!
Or... Oh!
How about...
You use the same dress, but you wear it on your back.
So it's... Wait, so I turn around or...
No, no.
You pin it to your back.
You cover your back side, but you don't cover your front side.
That's a genius, because then people could just take the front version and then the back version and kind of sandwich them.
And then it looks like I'm wearing a normal dress.
Yeah, but then you would first have to provide them with your frontal view.
Are you okay?
I'm saying, you're not showing them the back side, because you don't have a real back side.
What?
Are you saying I'm a flat ass?
You are...
One-dimensional!
Oh yeah, that's true.
Wait, that is true.
Wait, no, I'm two-dimensional.
But it feels like you're one-dimensional.
What?
It's like telling a cat, do you know you're a cat?
What are you saying?
Meow?
I think cats don't think much.
Can I say a joke?
Okay.
That I came up with?
Yeah.
It's a joke only we VTubers can use.
Okay.
And I already used it.
So the other day I had a meet-and-greet.
And at the end of the meet-and-greet, you know, we always take a picture.
And so...
What is this excitement?
So the person was standing right by the monitor, and we were taking a picture.
And I was saying, get my good side!
Oh well, I only have one.
I
think I need to switch it to a T-shirt, I'm so sweaty.
You weren't getting that sweaty?
I have tears in my eyes.
Talk more!
Okay.
I can't hear you, I think you're being like, Discord cancelled.
Oh, wait, seriously?
I'm laughing at your joke.
Oh my god, oh my god.
Well, actually I was laughing at how hard you were laughing at your joke.
When you start laughing so hard, and then you start laughing at your laughing, because you don't understand why you were just endlessly laughing.
I know.
I get into that mood too, yeah.
Did you take off your shirt yet?
No, yeah, there's nothing underneath.
Can you introduce yourself to the audience while I go get a shirt?
Okay.
Hello everybody, my name is Midphantom.
I'm a ghost-made VTuber.
Kiara is... she's chatting, she's saying something.
Our comedic genius, Tencho.
Um, yep.
For those who didn't understand the backless dress thing, I did a karaoke and I wore a red dress.
And, um, I don't know, people are making a big old deal about it.
Yeah, but, um...
Are you okay?
Yeah.
I think I am.
Oh, it smells like fresh laundry.
Ooh, nice.
Did you explain to them what we were even talking about?
Yeah, a little bit.
Good, good, good, good.
I just need to calm down.
Deep breaths, deep breaths.
Yeah.
Well, well, well, well, my dear child.
Today, we are gonna play Age of Empires 2.
Woohoo!
Mm-hmm.
And, yeah, so, you know, I had a little bit of an Age of Empires arc.
Was it last year, I think?
Yeah, I heard about this.
Or maybe even before.
Yeah, and I even got a coach, um, and everything.
Really?
And I got like, yeah, I was like on my way to getting good.
It's pretty good, you know.
Okay, okay.
But, don't worry, I was still like, every time it came to like, starting a battle, initiating a battle, I was crumbling with anxiety.
It's so bad.
The thought of it still makes me nervous.
I just want to forever, like, just build my economy and nothing else.
Oh, you don't want to engage in the battle.
You want to just...
Yeah, no.
Become the best of the biggest.
Ideally.
But, anyway, so, I was doing that for a while, but it's been a while.
I don't remember much, but I saw you the other day playing.
And I normally... I don't really have the time and also, like, the mental space anymore to watch Vtubers for a long amount of time, you know?
Maybe I'll peek into a stream for a few minutes, but that's about it, usually.
But I was watching your stream, like, for hours.
What?
Yeah.
Oh my gosh, do you like me or something?
No!
Yeah, maybe.
But, like, there's something... I didn't realize this as I was playing it, even though, you know, it's fun playing it too, but...
I realized, oh, Age of Empires might be actually extremely chill to watch as a viewer.
Amazing.
But here you are, playing it again.
Yeah, so to provide that same joy that I felt watching you once again to others.
She's a woman of the people.
I always am, I always am.
I do what's best for everybody.
So, you know, that's what we're doing today.
People shall spectate at our noobness.
Yeah, sorry, we're noobs.
Except you apparently had professional training.
No, but, as I said, like, I'm good with maybe building economy, but I already forgot all the key shortcuts, so I do everything with mouse.
Oh, yeah, I did that too.
So don't worry, I won't be that fast.
I feel like we should set the general game speed to slow.
Okay.
So that we have more time.
We gotta get into it, we gotta get warmed up.
Yeah, you know...
Wait, do you remember an important thing?
Yeah, a co-op campaign.
No.
Okay, okay.
I've tried Wololoing here and there, but, like, it rarely works out well.
They always, like, get lost and die because they're so small.
Is that all you got in terms of Age of Empire memes?
Is that all you got?
I have... King of the Losers.
I don't know that.
What?
You don't know the King of the Losers?
I know it's you.
Oh, what?
Eleven, eleven.
Eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Did you try out the cars yet?
Cars?
The cars?
Yeah, there's... You can turn on cheat codes for funny...
Oh, no, I didn't.
I forgot last time.
Yeah, you need to play it again.
Go, go, go.
Okay, will do.
The cars are funny.
But even the cars didn't bring me to victory that easily.
Anyway, we still haven't started the game.
Wow, surprise.
Because I wanted to ask you guys... Because I want to do a co-op campaign with this girl.
But, guys, do you have a recommended one that's, like, not too difficult that we should play?
Also, I want to switch you back to...
Saladin.
Are you okay?
That was suddenly loud.
Yeah, you were loud.
I was... I was loud?
Yeah.
Really?
Did I change volume?
You screamed in my ear.
Oh.
Maybe this game... Against bots?
Yeah, that was the plan.
Against bots.
We might do, like, a versus later.
Maybe.
How we're feeling.
If you're feeling it.
Atilla... I only saw the first couple, okay?
But they're not sorted like that.
People are saying Atilla is easiest.
Okay, where is... Where is Atilla?
Ah, these ones.
Okay.
I wonder if I did any of these already.
Maybe not.
Saladin.
Okay, so we start with the first one.
Scourge of God.
We're making a room right now.
Yeah.
In the lobby.
You got this, girl.
You got this.
You... You have the password.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
I do.
Let me, uh...
Oh, but wait!
Hm?
This is just us.
Let me undo.
Huh?
Wait, what?
I... I need to make a new one.
Because I think in the create lobby screen... Yeah, you can choose how many players.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And I only had two.
Should we do four or so?
Why would we do more?
If it's just us.
No, because, like, we wanna be together, right?
But there's... There has to be some enemy.
We can't just be friends.
Oh, right, right, right.
Oh!
Yeah.
Is the campaign not a story?
Actually, I'm confused.
I... I don't know.
Do we need... Do we... Do I need to account for an enemy NPC?
Yeah.
Wait.
I guess so, because story mode... They have already...
Oh, people are saying not in campaign.
Campaign has AI by default.
In the campaign, you just do co-op.
Okay, so I just choose two players.
Okay, okay, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, the lobby is open again.
Same password.
But why am I the Huns?
Am I supposed to be the Huns?
How do I find your lobby?
Search lobby.
So now I will show...
Oh!
Do you need my game ID?
I think so.
Okay.
So this is super safe.
What the heck is that?
Oh my god.
It's like you're sending me your IP address.
It's after the slash.
The last slash.
That's where it starts.
Okay, okay.
Searching.
Send her an invite.
Searching for games.
How do I find it?
Are we friends in Steam?
Oh, I don't know actually.
You went to multiplayer, right?
And then made the lobby.
So find custom game.
Yeah.
Okay, we gotta be Steam friends.
Maybe that will make it easier.
Maybe.
Okay.
Starting from scratch.
But I will give you my friend code.
Too late.
I already sent it.
No!
I don't remember how to add friends.
Guys, look at all these lobbies.
They're full of noobs.
Noob, noob, noob, noob, noob.
They will be joined by more noobs soon.
How do I add friend?
Okay woman, just give me your Steam account.
Where do I find...
Go to your name and then friends on Steam.
Yeah, I could probably send you one now.
I sent one.
Okay, add a friend.
Wait, pending invites.
I don't have any.
Who did you...
There are no users to match your search.
What?
You sent me a fake code.
No, it's real!
You don't want to be with me?
It's real, it's real, it's real!
I'll give you mine and this one will be real.
This is like you're giving me a fake phone number.
Aren't you missing one number?
No!
I literally clicked copy and paste.
Add a friend and to friend code paste.
There you go, I sent you one.
Yippee!
You sent me one!
Mint Fantome.
You know, up until today I was like still always calling you Meido Minto.
You can still say that.
Some people just call me maid.
That one is annoying.
But I don't mind it, Meido Minto.
But like, then I checked your Twitter and everything and I realized, oh damn, she really doesn't have maid mint written anywhere.
It's just Mint Fantome.
What happened?
Were you ever maid mint?
Yeah, some places.
I think.
Interesting, okay.
Okay, we're friends now.
Yippee!
Just from today.
I'm gonna unfriend her after you guys, don't worry.
Don't lie!
That's not even funny because nobody would believe that.
Even for a second.
Okay, let me try to invite you now.
Invite me.
What the?
I just clicked something?
My screen went black.
Oh, I'm in ranks.
Ah, there you are.
Oh, you're naked.
Pretty much everybody has a basic...
Can you change your person?
Picture.
Probably.
Why does Crony have a different one?
Interesting.
Invite.
Retract.
My game is really slow all of a sudden.
Restart.
Hold on, I'm gonna restart.
Yeah, I'm gonna restart my game.
Oh, oh gosh.
Don't send... Oh gosh, I'm getting a bunch of error reports.
Don't send.
Oh my god, what's happening in Korraka?
Don't send, don't send, don't send.
I got like five error reports.
We're okay.
From where?
From Windows?
From the game.
Okay.
Sus.
I don't have mods, so...
Okay, I'm okay.
Are you gonna invite me?
Yes.
Here, there you go.
Pending invitation.
Wait, it disappeared.
Where did it go?
What?
There it is, there it is.
I got it, I got it, I got it.
No!
No, no, no.
What happened?
You're not in, right?
No, no.
What is happening?
Are you...
Let me in, let me in, let me in.
Vlad Dracula left.
Accept!
I'm in, I'm in.
You're not.
I'm not.
Let me in.
I could do this forever.
Accept.
I'm in, I'm in, I'm in, I'm in.
I'm so exhausted already.
Too much fun.
Wait, you're like a sexy lady.
I muted your chat.
You can't chat with me now.
What do you mean?
I have too much power.
Fine, I'll mute your chat.
Okay.
Fine.
I'm gonna report you.
No.
No, I'm gonna report you.
I'm gonna report you.
Okay.
So...
What else should we look at?
Standard?
Oh yeah, standard is finally...
Shut up.
Mute.
No!
You can't...
Don't silence me!
There's no way to change the speed of game.
It's okay.
I think we got it.
I don't know.
Okay.
We got this.
We're even.
Am I gonna carry you?
No, I can hold my own.
Okay.
Really?
Yeah.
Together.
I was hoping together we'll be stronger.
Okay.
We're the dream team.
Yeah.
I believe in our combined power.
Okay.
Press I'm ready.
Oh, okay.
I almost left lobby.
The game begins now!
Story time.
Why did he keep it?
I'm gonna have that kind of decor.
To be or not to be.
Did I skip?
Did you skip?
You're saying something that's not here.
Because he's holding the skull.
Attila the Honey.
Cutie Honey.
Please!
I hear horses stepping.
They're coming!
I think you're ahead of them.
I hear the barbarians!
What?
You're crazy!
There's no barbarians.
They might be like all over the place.
Can you hear them?
I hear them now.
I stopped taking my meds so I can hear them.
Scary.
Okay, I'm done with the story.
I'm awaiting you on the battlefield.
You just cut off the man!
He was speaking!
Wait, who am I?
I'm purple.
What are you?
No, I'm purple.
No, we're purple.
They're purple!
Wait, then who are we?
For now we're just following them I think.
Or looking at them.
This way Attila!
The deco is kind of ugly.
Are they all our enemies?
Attila must survive.
Kill Bleda and return...
Wait, who are we?
You're orange.
I'm yellow apparently.
I don't see us.
Not yet, not yet.
But are we all against everybody?
No, we are with the... I see it now.
Look at the bottom right.
There are all kinds of different icons.
We are with the Huns and we are with each other because we all have the same...
Wait, we're supposed to do stuff.
Wait, can you control these?
Because I can.
No, I can't do anything.
Oh ok.
We're probably just going through the story right now.
Ok.
I guess I gotta do the story part.
You gotta do the hard work.
Come on!
By the time I was just standing around the enemies are already working on their economy.
Where are we going?
Wait, I'm the archers?
Am I the archers?
Wait, why are the purples attacking?
Kiwawa, this is all you?
This is all you?
This is unscripted?
Maybe just run.
Maybe you should...
No, no, no.
I would never run.
I'm not a coward.
I believe in you.
Kill the small guys.
No!
You keep on fighting bro!
Wait, he is also against me.
Shit!
Wait, I'm supposed to survive.
Am I already failing?
Kiara, we were supposed to team up.
They said this was easy.
This wasn't easy chat.
This was not easy at all.
You should have run away.
Can we do it again?
Ok, re...
Rematch.
Why is it better?
I went...I left.
Oh, I'm looking at the map.
Where would I be?
Top right and then click on go to menu or whatever.
Ok.
Should I have ran?
You had the best military.
I was orange, I had nothing.
Your story arc was about to still unfold.
I didn't even have the chance to live.
I was still in the womb.
Sorry guys, it's difficult to pay attention to the story when I'm trying to also talk to her.
But I have to bait the boar and then let it kill Bleda apparently.
Then maybe you can also play after that probably.
Wait, did I...return?
No, what?
Guys, this is...
How to...
New lobby.
Invite me.
Ok.
I'm gonna bait the boar.
That boar is gonna rip that other guy up and then I will crawl out of his dead body.
And that's how I will start the game.
Wait, should I set a password if I can invite you anyway?
Is it necessary?
Nah, just invite me then.
Maybe you should do the beginning.
You got this, you got this.
I believe in you.
And I saw the map.
I know everything now.
Click where?
There's nothing here.
There should be an invite.
No!
Get out of the map!
I'm not in the map!
Are you in the main menu?
Yes.
Ok.
Invite!
Do you have my invite?
No.
Are you trolling me again?
No, I'm really not!
You're trolling me!
No, I'm not!
No!
This is what you get for crying wolf.
No, no, no!
What are you seeing right now?
Nothing.
Where are you?
I'm in the main menu.
Ah, you gotta go to the multiplayer lobby apparently.
Oh, what?
No, I got invited.
Somebody said that.
Ok, I'll try.
Find custom game.
Apparently, you just gotta be in the lobby in order to receive the invite in the first place.
Here, I invite you again.
Oh, you invite me again.
What?
I'm in!
I feel like that's...
Are you in?
Oh, you're in.
Ok.
Once again.
So...
I have to bait the boar and let it kill the other person.
Yeah.
I understand.
I think I understand.
Are you ready?
Yeah, I'm ready.
I'm ready.
I press the button.
I'm so ready.
Ok.
Ok, we got this.
We're the Huns.
We got... We're the Hunnies.
We're the Hunnies.
You're watching what I'm doing, right?
Yeah, yeah.
I'm judging you.
I'm...
No, no, no.
Don't judge me.
Support me.
Tell me what to do.
Ok, ok.
You wanna skip this?
Yes.
Kill Bleda.
Kill that guy.
This guy sucks.
Ok, that guy.
I'm on the white horse.
There.
There she is.
Oh, they were serious about that.
Ok, ok.
Yeah, it's just a pig.
You gotta go, Kiwawa.
You gotta go.
He's gonna go.
Don't we need like some people watching us so they can attest and witness?
I'm watching.
I'm the witness.
Boar, follow me.
Ok.
There we go.
He's already... I didn't even do anything.
Nice.
Go Boar!
But leave the horse alone.
The horse did nothing wrong.
Go Boar!
Maybe you should attack him too.
I don't think I can.
It would be unrespectful of me.
I don't think that guy should live though.
He attacked us.
See, he's dying anyway.
Oh, and now I get the rest of the Boar.
And I bring back home the meat.
Ok, I have to return to the camp.
Yeah, and then I become your people.
Yes, hopefully.
My dream will come true.
Hello everybody!
Hello guys!
What?
No!
It was the Boar!
I told you I need someone to witness it.
Oh, I think I'm these guys.
Oh, attack!
Kill them.
I'm gonna kill them.
Purple!
Purple, go away!
Yeah, kill the purple!
Kill the purple!
Yeah!
I'm here.
I'm your people.
This is me.
I'm here to follow you.
But I'm the protagonist.
You are the protagonist.
Oh wait, I'm a Deku.
This guy.
They paid tributes.
Nice.
And what now?
We gotta...
Zero out of two enemies.
Wait!
There is a guy coming!
He is a blue man.
He looks like a scout.
Get him!
Go get him!
I killed him.
Good.
Good job.
But that didn't count to...
My bloodlust!
Maybe we gotta go up?
Where the other purples attacked us?
We should free them.
Where are they?
They uncleared some of the map for us.
Oh yeah, we're going to orange.
Wait, I'm orange.
Is this your home?
Damn girl, you live like this?
I'm gonna start mining.
Can we even reach from here?
I think we gotta go the other way.
Yeah, go around.
Because there is a big cliff.
Oh, there is like rubble over here.
What did you do?
You really took out some people.
I didn't do anything.
I'm just one protagonist.
Hold on, I'm gonna move over.
Why is this guy not working?
Do I need to spawn?
Sorry guys.
Is this necessary?
Wait, hold on.
Is that you?
Yeah, hold on.
I'm trying to move over so people can see.
I always forget what the UI is.
Where am I?
I'm killing him!
I killed him.
See, there is like rubble here.
Why are we so close to everybody?
Oh my God!
Kill them!
Blue is evil!
Kill!
More rubble!
Ok, welcome to my house!
Oh my God, give me a tour!
We are in like the stone ages still.
I'm sorry.
It's a little embarrassing.
We are humble.
We are like, you know...
We got...
I can make people.
I'm gonna make more people.
I'm kinda concerned that we are not fast enough.
What are you talking about?
Where are those enemies?
I have four...
No!
We are not doing anything.
I have ten people that are not doing anything.
Oh wait, I only have one guy.
Get some berries.
They are working.
I don't know if this is important right now though, because I feel like this first campaign would just make you do whatever is in the objective.
Then why did they give us the option?
But we don't want any idle villagers.
No, no.
I don't think there is anything... Oh wait!
Horses!
Lots of horses.
Why was that scary music?
Right?
It's very terrifying.
Scary.
There is nothing here.
There is nothing over here.
I wonder if they expect us to breach the walls to the red side.
To red?
Okay.
Because that's the only place where I saw enemies.
Why can't I make more soldiers?
You can't?
I can't.
Oh, then you probably need more houses.
I have an idle one.
I don't think so.
Can you make a house?
Oh, no.
We can't make houses, so I don't think they expect us to like really boom or anything.
Okay, let's go invade.
We're just supposed to kill.
This gate looks weak.
Weak.
We got this.
Maybe they'll just open the door.
I'm gonna...
Hunts don't need houses.
Wow, this place is really destroyed.
I think it's this place where I'm at.
Really?
Okay.
Panzer Nomads.
We don't live like this because we don't live there at all.
Oh my gosh!
I'm getting attacked.
Wonderful.
Kill!
Oh, I think I understand.
They don't mean like two singular enemies.
They mean two full, like...
Full, yeah.
Folks of people, like all of them.
All of them.
Kiwama, I think I have just three guys left and they're not doing so hot.
What the heck?
No!
But you didn't start off with so many though, did you?
I think my guys are a little weak.
Orange guys are still in the Stone Age, you know, it's kind of hard for us.
I'm also in the Stone Age.
No, you had a better building than me.
Eh?
No, I'm also in the Stone Age.
Oh, well Takaki-chan is in the Stone Age, but Bleda was in one above.
Do we even need to...
Don't... Pay no attention to the towers.
But it's fine... Why do they have so many towers?
They're not shooting anyway, so...
Yeah, we can ignore.
I think you can advance now.
What?
Oh, I can.
But what... Am I actually supposed to do something?
How am I supposed to heal?
There is no healing.
We just fail.
Okay.
One guy is really into...
Here we go.
Gosh, there's so many...
There's so many towers.
Don't bother with them.
We gotta get the hunt captive too.
How are we supposed to... We're just like 10 people.
They probably already have like 50.
50.
Where are they?
Maybe we should have gone to the red.
I'm here!
We're here.
I think we should...
No, let's go!
Let's go!
Where do we even...
Oh, they are really advanced.
Kill!
Wait, I'm gonna go get some guys.
Save them!
Kill them!
Oh, those people!
Oh, they'll join us!
Kill them!
Kill!
I mean, not kill.
Destroy the gate.
I saved them.
You?
Well, at least we're in Funeral Age.
No, we're OK.
We're OK.
You have to collect them, I think.
They are yellow people.
OK, OK, OK.
Collect them and then we'll bring them.
Oh, there are some orange ones too.
Oh, there are?
OK, OK.
OK, time to go home everybody!
What's with the...what's with this one?
What's with the green?
OK, let's go home.
Free him!
Free!
No, I think this guy is an enemy, right?
It says free the scythian scout.
Oh, OK, we gotta free him.
Nice, good job everybody.
Teamwork.
Stop bothering me!
They're hitting me from the side!
I have auto-heal or something, it seems.
I'm also killing.
Nice.
Oh gosh, they keep reproducing!
No!
You are free, my friend.
OK, let's go home.
Time to go wherever you please.
I have just one guy...we both have just one guy left.
A truce!
Follow green!
Oh, OK, OK.
He went to the left.
A truce!
But should we send the villagers...
No, they need to stretch their legs a little bit.
OK, OK.
Oh gosh, watch out.
How are we doing?
The Roman Empire!
Wait, where did green go?
Where did green go?
He disappeared in the woods!
Oh my god, he tricked us!
He sent us over here!
To get shot at!
It's OK.
Come on guys, let's go home.
We'll deliver them.
We'll find him.
He should be close by.
Which way are we going?
Villager army.
Yeah, should I just send them?
Wait, I'll send them to work at home.
OK.
I forgot how to do it.
You go here, and all my other people...
I think that's everybody.
OK, hold on, I'm going to send them to work.
Everybody go to the mines.
I can't multitask like this.
I can't.
Where's my character?
Oh, I saw the green scout on the map.
Yeah, I saw him.
He was in my village.
Now it's just us.
There they go.
Let's go towards our village then?
Or is he just doing his job now, scouting?
It says bring Attila to the...
We gotta go to the village.
OK.
Where...
Our...
No, his village.
Yeah, we gotta go to his village.
We gotta go find him.
This is so much for my brain.
Oh my god!
We see!
It's huge!
Wait, you...
What?
Wait, we have horses.
We do have horses.
Wait, why do they want...
Why do they want horses when we freed them?
They should be giving us horses.
Oh, they can't get out.
Well, I have free horses at home.
At least.
Where do you have horses?
Over there.
Do we have to pick them up?
Oh, these are my horses.
OK.
I'm bringing horses.
I got three horses.
Oh, maybe it can be...
Ah, there's free random horses.
Ah, so...
Right now, on the map, I found like random stray horses.
Yeah.
And when you select them, you can tell them to go up.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's what I was doing.
Alright, come here.
OK, OK, OK.
Alright, they'll have plenty of horses.
I have three horses coming in.
Coming in hot.
Four horses coming in hot.
Really?
Yeah.
I'm also sending in free right now.
OK.
Oh, I saw... I see three in your village.
I see three in your village.
In the yellow village.
Yeah, but those have to kind of be like... like freed.
Can my villager open this up for them?
Wait, they can't get out.
Yeah, how do you...
OK, we got six horses.
Oh, we got seven horses.
Wow.
Any more?
Maybe we can give them a different animal and sell it as a horse.
Destroy the post.
Oh, what if we disguise a donkey and say it's a horse?
I'll send three more.
I first have to destroy the fence.
OK, I'm gonna go search for horses.
Oh wait, you can find three?
You found three?
Yeah, well, in the village.
I'm opening up the fence.
Am I supposed to actually be trying right now?
Like, should I be doing stuff like this?
Oh, I found a wolf.
He didn't talk to me.
Thank goodness.
Oh, they're chopping wood or something there.
No, no horse.
That'll take a while.
No horse.
Any horse over here?
I can't.
There's a horse.
Here, maybe?
What if we send them deer and say it's a horse?
Yeah, send deer.
You're not supposed to look a gifted horse in its mouth or something like that.
You know that?
What?
It's a German saying.
Oh, what does it mean?
I'm not sure.
I just saw a green scout getting killed, but there's several, so I guess it was whatever.
Did you ever get your horses out?
I'm working on it.
Guys, what does it mean?
Don't look a horse in the mouth.
It's got big teeth.
It exists in English too, apparently.
Really?
Don't look a gift horse in the mouth.
Oh, is it like a Trojan horse?
Because you'll find people inside.
Yeah, maybe.
Gosh, the green empire is huge.
No, it's more like the meaning is to be grateful of a gift.
Don't nitpick it.
Don't question it.
But I guess it does come from the Trojan horse, but for that case, you should question it.
I think, yeah, that makes me want to not trust it.
Oh, I found two more horses at the edge of the map.
Okay, I'm sending them.
Where were they?
But I still need my free, I think.
We just need one more then, if you have two more.
One!
Oh, one in total.
Come on, there's gotta be one more on this map somewhere.
Are you exploring?
No.
Well, whatever the green guy explores, I can see actively.
The thing is, I wonder if the blue village still had horses that we could steal.
Well, I was just looking in there, but I can't see any.
Like, it's all grayed out.
This is gonna take forever.
Destroying the fence.
We could go to the red...
Why is the red...
How do I delete a building?
Oh, because they're trapped in there.
I see what you mean now.
Ah!
Okay!
Okay, well...
I am delivering... Wait, just one horse.
We don't need to do more than that.
Oh, you look at a horse's teeth and gums to see how healthy they are, but you shouldn't be judging how good...
Oh, I see.
How wise.
Yeah, where's my guy?
You're also there.
Okay, last horse is coming!
I hope they want them there.
Yeah, you gotta send them to the flag.
Okay, this is so chaotic, I'm so...
It's okay, we're fine!
We got the horses!
Specific goals!
But we still have 0 out of 2 enemies defeated.
It means probably blue and red.
Yeah, surely they'll help us with that, right?
The green ones will help.
Oh my gosh, I love the videos where they change the...
What's happening?
Oh!
We have men!
Oh my gosh!
Look!
They're coming from the west!
They joined us!
The dogs are coming!
Let's go!
Let's attack...
Let's attack red?
It's probably gonna give us an objective.
Oh yeah.
Blue should already be dead!
Why aren't they...
They should abdicate.
Let's go to blue.
Okay, let's go kill!
We already did some basic damage anyway.
Kinda.
Well, we can...
Yeah, we did.
Where's their town center?
Let's kill these guys.
Oh, kill, kill, kill.
Oh, here's some more coming.
Where are they coming from?
From where?
We cannot lose!
We cannot lose this!
Yeah!
They gave us all their men!
Stay away!
Stay away from dangerous arrow buildings.
Okay.
Oh, there's a town center here!
Oh, that's a blacksmith.
Just kidding.
Is it this?
Oh no, that's a university.
Well, once we do enough damage, they will eventually just say, Okay, we're out, I think.
Yeah, that's true.
Oh, but come a bit deeper.
I don't know why they're...
What's this?
This looks like a barracks.
Oh yeah, defeat it so that they can't make more men.
Actually, I'll do this one.
I'll do this one so they can't make archers.
It's always hard to tell which building is what you're looking for.
I'm trying to... Oh my gosh, I'm getting attacked from all angles!
No!
No, why are you dwindling?
Your numbers are dwindling!
I know, I know, I know!
I'm trying to figure out!
Oh my gosh!
Come here, come here, come here!
Oh no, I lost a man!
I lost a man.
Come here, come here!
I need you, woman!
I'm trying, but they're still attacking me!
I'm supporting you!
Stay away from the towers!
I'm trying to defeat the tower!
Go so that not both towers can shoot you.
But only...
Also, if they don't have murder holes...
If you're really close to one, they can't shoot you if you're like one block away.
There's also guys attacking us, so...
Attack this.
Well, I can't be helped.
Go!
My men!
Oh, we crumbled, we crumbled, we crumbled!
I could probably make more...
I'll make a couple more.
The barracks is falling!
What do I make?
But I don't know if I want...
Do I want walking people?
Wait, you can make more people.
I'll make a couple more people.
Oh my gosh, they have another barracks.
How do you make more people?
Maybe you can't.
I can't.
I'm too sad.
I have to multitask so much.
What's going on?
I can't look right now.
What's going on over at the blue?
H2?
Oh, I can go to H2.
I can advance to the feudal age.
You can?
Yeah!
I'm advancing!
Zing!
The chat told me.
Alright, we're gonna kill these guys.
Really?
Look, they are not even spawning more men.
They're weak, weak, weak.
This is not how you play Age of Empires!
What?
Yes it is!
We're pillaging!
Can make boat?
Wait, where is boat?
We don't have boat?
Yeah!
We're pillaging!
And we're taking down the city!
Really?
Are we?
We're gonna take all their money!
Yeah!
Well, it's a little slow, but you know.
It's a little slow.
Alright, looks good.
Nothing is attacking us, right?
Why are they not stopping?
I don't know.
Why are they not leaving?
I have a lot of gold.
Let's see.
I can make more buildings.
Okay, this is good.
Wait, I can build a barracks.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, let's go!
Make the barracks.
I'll make some skirmishers and some archers.
I need more food.
Build this.
I advanced!
I don't remember any key shortcuts anymore.
Sorry, chat.
I advanced.
Okay, we took down two buildings.
Man, we're wasting all our strong units.
No, we're not getting attacked.
It's okay.
The blue will give up eventually.
Why don't they give up earlier?
Blue is AFKing.
It's true.
This is not how you play the game.
There's no point.
Guys, chill, chill, chill.
Maybe I shouldn't...
Why am I so close to red?
I'm camping at their gate.
I know.
They are so close.
It's kind of insane.
Okay, now this.
Make some boats.
Fishing.
Fishing ship.
Okay, this is how you play the game, baby!
Is it?
Yeah, I think so.
I'm upgrading.
I can create men!
I don't have enough food.
Can you also create some women?
I'll think about it.
Am I ready for Castle Age?
What do I need?
I need more food for Castle Age.
Blue is holding the game hostage.
Report!
Go become food.
What the heck, man?
Give up already!
What's wrong with him?
They are tough.
They have nothing...
After we defeat that, they have nothing else to create fighters.
Yeah, you would hope so.
But sometimes you think so and then the enemy...
Like, you leave it because you think you destroyed everything they have.
And then you leave and go to the next enemy.
And in the meantime, the enemy that you thought you already completely demolished...
Comes back five times stronger, rebuilding their economy.
No!
These guys are baby wimps.
Happens to me.
I hope so.
They are baby wimps.
Little baby wimps.
We're okay.
Baby wimps?
Yeah.
We're okay.
You come to the stone.
We need more stone.
Where are my boats?
Oh wait, I can go to Castle H.
I'm ready for Castle H, baby.
Then I'll just place the castle right in front of their gate.
Yeah, I'm trying to... I realized...
If I had known from the beginning that we do have to kind of work on our economy...
And not just go run around and do fun things, then I would have done that from the start.
But okay.
Here we go.
We're working hard now.
And hardly working.
Yeah.
Okay, now we build economy.
Where are my boats?
How do I send them to go fishing?
Are you using boats to go fishing?
Yeah, but they won't leave.
Alright.
I'll leave those waters to you.
What?
Click them?
Oh, I didn't realize I had to click them.
That's so funny.
Funny.
Okay, what else?
Oh my God.
Do you guys... Chat, do you think we have a chance?
Yeah!
We are 100%.
We have a chance.
We 100% have a chance.
Okay.
I believe.
Also, Chat, what do you think is going on with Blue?
What are their intentions?
I can't make sense of it.
Yes, it's fine.
Yeah, we got a chance.
We got this.
In the bag, baby.
They are so scared of us.
They are like...
They are shivering in their booties right now.
Chat seems very certain.
If they are certain, then okay.
I'm gonna be in castle age in two seconds.
I think they still have a stable.
That's why.
I need a feudal age building.
What's a feudal age building?
Oh, market, market.
Come on, lady.
I need a blacksmith.
Everybody is busy.
What?
Blue is attacking us now.
No, no, no, lady.
Oh, this tower.
This shitty-ass tower.
Nobody is attacking me.
Okay, you build...
Nah, ignore the towers.
Archery.
I don't know what to attack.
I don't see a stable.
Oh well, let's do the blacksmith.
The towers?
You think that the towers are the reason why we are still...
Why they are still alive?
What?
The towers.
No.
I'm taking out the...
What am I taking out?
What is this?
A stone wall.
No, no.
Take out the...
Should I just...
Should we just go away and ignore them?
They are not rebuilding, I think.
You said that they are going to rebuild.
Okay, okay, okay.
Where is the town hall?
Is this it?
It's a market.
This is...
It's the monastery?
Okay, it's the monastery.
I'm taking it out.
I'm joining you.
Oh, the market...
You go for the temple...
The market.
I'll go for the temple.
Okay, okay.
I can't deal with those fucking towers anymore.
Just ignore them.
They don't matter.
Chat, what's the shortcut for, like, selecting all of my fighting men?
Oh, yeah.
I don't want all, actually, though.
Nevermind.
I don't want all anyway, because some of them are down there.
I'll just do it like this.
How do I make a group again?
Like, I select them and then I...
What is it, like, city around and a number or so?
Ah, yeah!
Okay.
Okay, I just need...
I just need 800 food.
I'll go to the castle age.
I'm advancing.
Okay, good luck!
I'm advancing!
Do you know how to make enough food?
Do you know?
You're gonna be fine.
I have no stone.
Do you have a market?
You could buy stone at the market if you have enough of other...
Oh, true, true, true.
But only if you really think you have plenty of something else that you would trade.
I'm stingy.
I don't want to give anybody.
That's why I take over places.
I don't want to give them any, you know...
I've been making a small little army in my village.
Okay.
I got 19 ready to go in the village.
Nice.
And we're almost done with blue.
I hope.
I hope!
Yeah, we are.
Yes, kill the scout!
Waste your time by killing the scout!
Run after him!
Exactly, guys!
Wait, we destroyed it.
Why didn't they give up?
Let's destroy the blacksmith!
Blacksmith!
Take it down!
Everything!
We can do these two things at the same time.
Take it down!
Is it also the fishing port we need to take down?
Oh my gosh, the red empire is like a real empire.
Chiara, we're in trouble.
Yeah.
They're huge.
How are...
They're defeated!
Oh, blue is defeated!
Oh, when did they...
They recently must have...
Oh, yeah!
Okay, we can leave.
Okay, we're out.
We're out.
Well, let's not go to red directly.
Let's gather a big army and let's maybe make like trebuchets and stuff like that.
Yeah, I'm going home.
I'm gonna become...
Okay, I'm going into the castle age.
Okay, I'm already there.
See you soon in the castles.
Yeah, my people are stupid still.
And once you have a castle, maybe you can also build a castle in front of the gate.
No, but I don't think there's a point.
They're actually huge.
Just building one castle in front of their age... gate is...
I can't speak!
I'm too stressed out!
Don't be stressed out!
Don't be stressed!
Oh, wow, you got...
This is so much for me!
You got a good army.
Okay, I'll make a better army.
You can't make traps.
What the fuck?
Battering rams...
Gather here.
Yeah, sure.
We need... Once you can, make a siege and then build a few battering rams.
Okay, I...
My people have...
Kiara, my people have not even gone to a university.
They barely know what a wheel is, okay?
Like, they...
Please!
A wheel is triangle-shaped.
Just so you know.
Yeah, maybe I'll also...
Should I build...
University?
Is it a waste?
Oh my gosh, I'm almost at the castle age.
I'm almost at the castle age!
I do.
Exciting, exciting, exciting.
I have many foragers.
Let's go.
Do I even have...
The right camps?
Okay, yeah.
Oh, now they're bored.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, that's a green guy.
What are you doing over here, huh?
Why are there green men in my area?
This is my spot.
We're allies.
Excuse me.
Yeah, I'm about to build a thing.
Should I make a university?
Is it worth it?
Why not?
Yes, I think it's good because you can destroy...
You can make them study to destroy buildings faster and stuff, you know?
I guess.
No, that's gold.
Did you feel that?
I did.
I did feel that.
How do I open the chat, everybody?
I have full control over you.
I have a red in my territory.
I ignore him.
He's just a scout.
No!
No survivors!
Wait, I need to build a siege.
Okay, time for me to also build.
I'm gonna build...
I have no space, man.
I have no space.
I wanna build it, like...
Can I build here?
Will they feel too invaded?
Wololo.
Do you wanna be in charge of eventually having some monks and then...
Yeah, that's what I'm making.
...controlling them one by one?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's what I'm doing.
I'll leave it to you because I hate that.
What?
It's the best part.
Also, it seems like we cannot advance anymore further in this storyline.
So we are at maximum advancement.
No way!
I have so much gold.
Let's go.
Oh my gosh, I can do a husbandry.
I'm getting married!
Wow, husband!
That's also the only thing I can think of when I see husbandry.
What does this mean?
Oh, ok.
It's just a scout.
Sorry, you scared me.
I saw multiple guys, different colors.
They are so scary sometimes.
Yeah, I get it.
I know.
This game makes me so anxious when it comes to battle.
I don't wanna battle.
I can't.
I can't, man.
It's too much.
What is this?
Hey, scouty boy!
Oh, the greens!
Oh, see, I guess we still got the greens back.
Yeah, they are helping us out still.
Actually, are they though?
Are they ever gonna attack with us?
Or are they just chilling from now on?
Oh, they might be chilling.
But...
I think they are chilling.
It's ok.
They are just chilling.
We have a full... I'm getting monks.
They are coming here.
Everybody is setting up shop here.
I forgot.
You forgot?
I should have her do wood.
We need more wood.
Always keep an eye out that you have everybody on every resource.
Gold might not be as important unless you are spamming knights.
I think I'm gonna spam a few knights, so...
I got a lot of gold.
Are my boats not doing anything?
What are you guys doing?
Are you fishing?
Wood, please.
Enough wood.
Wishing I was fishing.
You could be.
I could not be.
Do you know how to fish?
IRL?
No.
No?
I wanna learn.
Don't you wanna learn?
Do you wanna go fishing?
Actually, I wanna learn spear fishing.
What?
That's intense.
But first I gotta learn diving.
What?
Yeah, in order to go spear fishing you gotta...
I guess you could do it while snorkeling in theory, but you probably wanna get a diving license.
Oh, my uncle knows how to dive.
Can your uncle teach us?
He could.
Nah, you need a teaching license, I think.
Oh, nevermind.
I also don't trust that guy.
Mark, trade gold for stone.
Trade gold for stone.
Wait, do I want gold or stone?
Oh yeah, see?
Research arson.
I'm researching arson so that we can defeat things better.
Okay, yeah, yeah.
Combined forces, baby.
And then...
We don't have them really invading our village.
I don't think I need to research that.
Wait, so if the Huns cannot build houses because they are nomads...
Are we capped at 75?
Then I don't want too many villagers.
Can you kill villagers?
Just send them into the red base.
Yes?
Oh, we're capped, so I don't want too many villagers.
Oh, so it's strategy.
Wow.
I'm just gonna make a big army.
Yeah.
They fire with more accuracy.
Oh yeah.
I'm getting all the upgrades.
I'm getting everything to make my guys crazy.
Oh, I don't have enough wood.
Okay, keep chopping.
Chop, chopping.
What's wrong?
I'm thinking...
Oh, a castle.
I need a castle.
Yeah, me too.
I'm gathering stone.
Wait, I could be gathering more stone.
I don't really have much stone.
A lot of stone.
You have stone?
It needs 650 stone.
If you have too much food or too much wood or so, you could...
What are you guys doing?
What are your orange people doing?
They're moving back.
Oh, I took the horses.
Sorry.
Oh, so you get the horses.
They're on my land.
I mean, I'm on this side of the river.
I'm just saying.
I was gonna say, if you don't have enough stone around you to gather, then you can just get it through the market.
I will have to buy.
Sell whatever you have an abundance of.
Okay, that should be good though.
All right, now I need a free person.
Well, technically, none of them are free.
Okay, I make my castle.
Maybe not right at the wall.
Maybe...
Maybe here.
I'm gonna take you.
Take you.
Come here.
I need two people.
This is a two-person job.
Make the castle.
Can you take over Blue's resource?
I guess we could, but I don't think we're that urgently in need of their resources.
Are they?
Oh, yeah, they gave up.
That's right.
I forgot.
Yeah, so we could, like, continue to use their headquarters for our purpose, but I don't think we need to do that.
I'm gonna start trading with you, okay?
Oh, we're gonna be my little trade partner.
Oh, sure.
All right.
Go at it.
Have fun.
I'll give you anything you want.
As long as I don't die from giving you too much.
No, we're gonna be...
I'll give you all I got.
Okay.
I want you to flourish.
Give me some of your people.
No, make your own.
Okay.
What are you doing?
Why are you not making more villagers?
Actually, never mind.
Don't make more villagers.
Where's your market?
Okay.
He's heading over.
He's gonna come trade with you.
Look at him go.
Oh my God.
Should I do that too?
Oh my gosh, our castles are gonna almost be touching.
Wait, do you see this?
Shut up!
Oh, you're also building at the bridge.
What made you think you need to build on the bridge?
We're so insane.
We're so insane, you guys.
This is crazy.
What are you making?
What units do you wanna make?
In the castle?
Anything's fine.
Look at your little army and my little army.
They're all gonna join forces together.
Oh my gosh, he's running.
He's so weird.
My horse is running.
He's so fast.
Go, go, go.
He's on a mission.
He's ready to trade.
But then...
Actually, maybe we should be stealing everything from green.
Yeah?
Yeah.
Because if we trade with each other, it's like kinda...
I don't know how that works, honestly.
I never really thought about it too deeply.
I wish I could build a bridge.
I've never done that before either.
Oh my gosh, he can go this way.
You're a trader?
I'm a trader, yeah.
He's a trader.
Did somebody ask what we're playing?
We're playing Definitive Edition, chat.
Can't you tell?
Why would I build an outpost?
Ah, here.
Okay, so how does this work?
We just right click on their market.
And then we get, like, resources.
Let's go!
I guess I haven't really built any farms.
Wait, what did I just do?
Oh, not the reseed.
How do I do this?
Which unit is better, chat?
A petard or a tarkhan?
There we go.
Petard is kind of cheaper on gold.
Or marauders.
Great tarkhans at stables.
What are you talking about?
Tarkhans.
They want tarkhans.
Chat wants tarkhans.
Oh, they're on horses.
I want elephants.
They're kind of expensive.
We need a lot more gold.
You want elephants?
Yeah.
I don't think you can have elephants.
No!
With the hounds?
Oh yeah, with the hounds.
No!
Keep dreaming.
Guys, look at our castles.
They're so close.
What if I just ended up attacking Kiara?
Oh, petard is a suicide bomber.
Shit!
Crazy, mad lad.
When they attack, they just die also.
We don't want that.
Chat, can you tell us when you think we are ready to go attack?
I think we're ready.
Yeah.
No, I don't think so.
I think red has elephants.
Oh, fuck.
That means we need the...
The bombers.
We need the vololo.
I have vololo.
I'll make more.
Skirmishers?
Go now.
More ramps.
Oh, more ramps.
Was that too much?
When you max out, then attack.
When you have 75 out of 75...
Tell me.
75 out of what?
Total of people.
Pikemen.
We need pikemen mostly.
I'll make more pikemen.
Oh, I don't have enough wood.
Because they're strong against elephants.
I think you probably said this earlier, but how do I open the chat?
The chat?
In the game.
No, I don't remember.
Enter.
Enter?
Ok,
ok.
You're good now.
By the way, I'm almost at 75.
Wait, what's the fun part?
What was that?
You can resign now.
Go resign.
Just resign.
Just go home.
Oh, wait.
I did the wrong one.
I can't hear anything you're doing.
Is it because you're muted?
Because I muted you?
Oh, you muted me!
I guess I still have you muted as a joke.
No, I can hear yours.
Oh, really?
So one-sided.
I know.
I'm sorry.
Well, just say what you want to say to me directly.
I don't want no in-between between us.
Ok.
All hail, king of the losers!
Oh, wow.
That just does not have any impact.
Wololo.
Fine, I won't wololo.
Guys, I can't tell what my army is.
We're gonna go now, because I'm full.
How about you?
Oh, we're going?
Well, soon.
How many army do you have?
Let me make more.
I'll make more Tarkin.
Oh, you're looking pretty good.
I'll make more Pikeman.
It's because I didn't have a lot of wood.
Oh, I can make more monks.
I wish I could separate my monks.
Oh, I have random horses in here.
Go away, random horses.
I think, are we supposed to eat those?
Can you?
Because we can't make them into units.
Are they there to be eaten?
That's a great question.
I'm gonna try.
No, you can't eat them.
What do you mean?
Did you try attacking them?
Well, with the person, yeah.
Also, they're stuck in my army.
I think they want to stay.
Oh wait, I can make them auto scout.
The horses alone?
With no rider?
Yeah.
They'll just go back into the wilderness.
They're like stuck in there.
My army is too packed.
Be free, horse!
Okay, there he goes.
Bring him over to me.
There he goes.
Off into the world.
Don't bother, guys.
Don't bother.
I'm trying to get them out of here.
Three horses stuck in here.
Go over there.
And you go over there.
Alright.
It was like control one or something, right?
I'm trying to separate my guys real quick.
Yeah, me too, me too.
What the hell are you doing?
Oh, he's like...
He's Fortnite.
We're almost about to go!
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
One, two, three.
I think that's all of the monks that I have.
Okay.
We got ten monks.
Probably.
What are you guys doing?
Okay, I have room for four more.
So I'm gonna make four more pikemen.
Okay.
Wait, you have monks too?
Yeah, I got ten monks.
Nice.
That's gonna be fun.
Ten monks?
That's kind of a lot.
I like the monks.
This is amazing.
Building hit points.
Okay.
Come here.
Maybe the university was useless.
I think...
Okay, control two.
Okay, you guys all come over here.
Okay.
Now we have that control.
And we'll have you guys be the third.
Okay.
Should I man my rams?
Is that how that works?
I'm almost out of gold.
Oh, wait.
You build...
this here.
And you.
It's okay, you don't need no more gold.
I guess we are about to destroy everything and win the game.
Yeah, we are about to do that.
I'm coming over here.
There we go.
I'm ready!
No, no upgrades.
Okay, ready?
Alright, alright, alright.
My monks are really slow though.
Why am I hearing that?
What is that?
Who's attacking?
Maybe it was just in our heads.
Maybe it was a preview of what's to come.
Or stuck.
Okay, I'll send my rams first to breach the walls.
Upgrades?
I did my upgrades.
I did all my upgrades.
Did you do all your upgrades?
Pretty much.
They have a big...
lake in between.
Maybe we should cross here actually.
Actually, yeah.
No, I think we have to...
Do you know where I mean with here?
Nope.
How do I point out something again on the map?
Oh, like where the deer are?
Up north?
No...
I don't think we can cross there.
There is a bridge.
I think the bridge is by... we have to go down?
Oh my gosh, they are attacking!
I see them.
I saw their army for a brief second.
Are there many?
We should just go down here.
Like kind of at the bottom, there is like a traversable path.
How did you make those things?
The battering rams.
I make those things.
Let's go down.
Signal alley.
Oh, I see, I see, I see, I see.
I saw it, I saw it, I saw it.
That's where we gonna go.
It seems like, you know, there is a certain path there.
Yeah, yeah, I see it, I see it.
Might take a while though.
I see...
Let's get moving, let's get cooking.
This area is quite tropical.
We are going to a beach paradise over here.
Are you guys...
Oh, I think I accidentally am sending my gold miner.
Oh, I see him!
There are some ships there.
Oh, they got battleships!
Oh my god!
Wait!
Avoid, avoid, avoid!
Oh, they are looking at the...
Avoid, avoid, avoid.
Should I send the rams for the ships?
No, I don't think so.
I don't think we should worry about them.
But they are right at the path that we are about to traverse.
Oh, you are right.
Good question.
Oh my god, he is attacking here!
Ah, just that one.
It's just a scout, right?
No, he was attacking your battering rams.
Ok, stop, stop, stop.
Ignore the ships.
Ok, let's try to, as quickly as possible, get over the water while ignoring everything else.
Yeah, yeah, just ignore the ships.
Oh gosh.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, I'm scared!
There is an elephant!
Elephant!
Wallow the shit out of him!
Wait, where did he go?
Wait, I'll let your monks go front.
Are you monks?
Your monks are so far!
Convert!
Oh, there is a traffic jam!
There is a traffic jam!
He's ours!
No, don't let him die!
Keep going!
Oh my gosh, keep going.
Good emergency food.
I don't think that worked.
I mean, we could kill those boats.
We destroyed the ship!
We are destroying them somehow.
Oh, you're doing it.
I got an elephant!
Ok, I will breach the walls.
The gates maybe in particular.
Get the elephant!
I am!
He's ours!
I don't know everything!
I don't know what to do!
My ramps can't get through!
Another elephant!
I'm getting him!
Wololo!
Yippee!
Now you get the elephants of your dreams!
Can you move those fat elephant asses and let my ramp through?
I'm trying!
Oh gosh, they got big things.
They are coming for us!
Wololo!
I don't have enough face.
The ramps are so confused!
Ah!
Just attack it!
Is this ok?
Is this going well?
I don't know!
More wololo!
I'm trying!
Oh we are in!
We are so in!
Are we?
I think... Are we dwindling?
Go inside!
Just go inside!
Go in!
They are sending more elephants!
It's hard to get in here!
I'm gonna kill some of the elephants!
Yummy!
It's really fast!
Oh this is fine!
Alright!
My ramps did nothing!
Go team go!
Let's enter!
Oh god!
I feel like we are not gonna be enough!
Wait!
Take down that one!
We are gonna be fine!
If that's all they are sending...
They are like... We don't have that much!
We might be ok!
I've only lost 5 men apparently!
So it could be worse!
I think I've lost more!
I'm getting more!
I'm getting more elephants!
Wait!
Stop!
What are you doing?
Yo!
Get those elephants!
Hell yeah!
Yeah!
I found the town center!
Oh you did?
I'm gonna go get them!
Can you get that elephant?
He's almost dead!
He's almost dead though!
He's dead!
Let's kill innocent people!
I don't think they are innocent!
They are not innocent!
The villagers are innocent!
No mercy!
Oh my gosh!
Elephant versus elephant!
I'm trying!
Oh I don't have him!
He's gonna trample all over me!
He's trampling all over me!
He's ours!
Stop it!
I need to make more...
No!
I need more face!
I don't have enough face!
They are building!
They are rebuilding!
Don't let Attila die!
He's fine!
He's very fine!
He's a fine man!
Oh we are fine!
We are gonna be fine!
But I'm making a few more pikemen while we are at it!
Ok, that's a good idea.
I'll make some more too.
We are so infiltrating their system.
Research...Oh I must have before convert buildings.
Oh, I don't have it.
Elephant, what are you doing?
Burn this down!
Nevermind!
Burn down this table!
Where are they getting more elephants from?
My elephants are fighting other elephants!
Yeah!
Take them down!
Oh god, I have so many resources.
Keep on making pikemen.
Faster!
Where is their castle?
What am I destroying right now?
A stable.
I have not seen the castle yet.
Probably deeper inside.
There is no deeper inside.
I have no more rams, but it's ok.
Should I go deeper?
I'm going deeper!
Me too!
Oh there are still more elephants.
I don't know if it's a bad idea.
Do you have monks still?
Yeah.
You have some random villagers coming in and like...
Kill this guy!
Which guy?
I got him.
He's trying to rebuild, but I won't let him.
Ok, looking good!
Looking good!
Go attack the university.
I should download more ram.
Attack the university!
No more rams.
It's a scam!
Rams are scam!
What is this?
Villagers.
You know what?
I'm taking out...
Something.
Wait, 9 out of 10 horses in the flagged area.
What?
How did we lose a horse?
I thought he was dying apparently.
Close to dying, but we victoriously...
We are victorious!
Really?
Was he doing so bad?
Wait, where is he?
He... No, he's still...
He had 164 out of 450 HP.
Where is he?
I don't even see him.
I don't know where you are.
We took them down.
Oh, it was right at the university.
Wait, no.
That's another villager.
What happened with our 9 out of 10 horses in the flagged area?
Why was it only 9?
That's what I said.
I don't know why it changed.
They ate one.
They got really desperate.
But we won.
So that's all that matters.
I wololoed those elephants, baby.
Good job!
How many monks did you have left in the end?
All 10 of them.
Oh shit!
Wow, you protected them well.
They were just chilling.
I've lost a lot of guys though.
Oh wait, I have even more monks.
Because there's two here.
Where did I get these monks?
Maybe you turned them into your own monks.
And they were someone else's too.
Oh maybe.
Nice!
Oh yeah, baby.
Attila!
He was the strongest!
I'm gonna miss our little village.
It was nice!
We built something nice!
Even though it was very chaotic.
The green place is crazy.
Yeah.
Oh look, their castle is so cool.
They had more playtime.
Yeah, I started at the feudal age.
Like crazy.
Now I'm castle age.
Wait, what are they?
There?
I don't know.
The Huns, they were like...
They were like the USA.
What?
USA?
Is that not a good comparison?
Thank god.
I'm glad we made it.
I was kind of like doubting because we started so late.
With like building our own army and stuff.
No, we were fine.
Oh, apparently not.
My comparison was wrong.
Well, well.
So shall we move on to the next chapter?
Or do you want to do like non-story game?
What do you want to do?
You...
Oh wait, I forgot.
We have more stories.
Did you read the story?
Yeah, kind of.
Yeah, yeah.
In the end, so Attila was victorious.
And then many, many people joined him.
Like from other...
Like the Scythians, I think the Persians too.
The Persians?
And even some people from the Roman Empire joined him.
And then, you know.
He had like a really...
He had much variety in his army.
I guess.
Yeah, I paid attention to 50%.
I was too excited to read, you know.
Oh yeah, our society was great.
Our military.
Look at my military.
Oh yeah, baby.
I took down the military.
Oh, let's go.
Your military...
The military score is like how many people you killed?
I don't know.
What is the military score?
Probably, probably.
How are the Persians so...
The red team is like crazy though.
Well, you know.
This is what they mean by AI taking our jobs.
Check at the top.
10 ,000 total score.
But they had way much more time to develop.
We are nomads, so...
Units created and killed.
You...
You raised 19 buildings.
We both lost 0 buildings.
Beautiful.
Yeah, we are the best.
You got like extra points for converting enemies.
We got 6.
We got 6 elephants.
Ok, you had the largest army in the end.
But I would say partially that is because I was more in the front lines and lost more.
Oh my gosh, the Persians were crazy with their economy.
The Persians...
But you also were really good with your economy.
Oh my gosh.
I'm gonna step up my game, you know.
I know.
You got the economy down.
Oh hell yeah.
Our coin is rising.
Yippee!
Stonks, stonks!
So chat, what do you think since we can't decide?
Should we do another story chapter or should we do like a skirmish?
Yeah, what do you guys want?
Tell me what you want, what you really, really want.
No, tell me what you want, what you really, really want.
I wanna, I wanna, I wanna, I wanna...
Oh, we all have castles.
Wait, I never saw their castle.
Did you see their castle in the end?
No, I didn't, because it did say we had castles in it.
I didn't see it though.
Maybe it just looks different.
Skirmish, skirmish, skirmish.
1v1?
They want 1v1 skirmish.
You versus me.
Alright.
1v1?
Are you scared?
Yeah.
Me too though.
It's no...
It's no hard feelings.
It's just, you know...
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, no, yeah, yeah.
Some people are saying 2v2.
Us versus AI or both of us partner up with one AI?
Yeah, which is it?
2v2?
I think we together should fight the AI.
I think I would prefer that.
I'm scared.
If I fight you, I'm scared.
Yeah, yeah.
You should be, but I would also be panicking, don't worry.
Okay, okay.
Us versus two AI.
Let's do that.
I'm gonna make a room.
It's gonna be fun.
2v1 hard AI?
Oh my god.
No, no, no, no, normal, normal, normal.
They said that we could take like, us versus one...
Oh wait, that's what you said.
2v1, right?
Yeah, that is reasonable apparently, but...
If it's one hard AI...
You wanna try?
Challenge, challenge.
Yeah, I guess, actually.
And we wouldn't have to divide our focus, we could just...
Yeah, I agree.
Okay.
It's a challenge, it's a challenge, you guys.
Challenging.
You can help us too, if you want.
Chat, you mean?
Yeah.
They're already always helping us, aren't they?
I know.
Thank you.
So...
Just, chat, would you...
Would you forgive us if we at least put the game speed on casual though?
Because we're very, very slow thinkers.
Oh, I said game speed on normal.
I'm not sure if it was how we just played.
If the co-op...
I think the co-op game speed is different, so I can't really compare it to that.
That's fine, that's fine.
Okay.
We're gonna have casual speed...
Hard AI, resources standard... Is the rest fine?
Random map or should we choose one?
Did you hear that?
No.
Oh, I still have you muted.
Okay, I'm unmuting you now.
Shut up!
What should I play?
I wanna play Portuguese.
It's 30.
That should be bigger.
Shut up!
I'm gonna mute you!
Okay, sorry.
No, don't mute me!
I'll be good, I'll be good!
I'll be good, I'll be good.
Small?
Because we're free players.
Okay, I'll unmute you again.
Don't risk it.
Don't challenge it.
I'm player one.
You really wanna play Random Civilization?
Probably because...
Yeah, I like it.
I like to... I don't know a lot about any of them, so I'm just kind of...
Let's see what you'll get.
I hope it has good synergy with me.
Wait, we're not together in the same team right now.
Now we are, right?
Oh, I made it to Portuguese?
Oh, wait, I think...
Do you have to be?
No, I think we just have to be... So change your team on the right side.
The team's gotta be the same.
Okay.
Oh, I was player one.
I was player...
Wait, how do I get the invite... How do I invite the AI?
I want green.
Won't it, like, automatically add the AI?
Oh, um... I don't know how to add it.
I'm not gonna invite AI, right?
Click on open.
Open?
Open, open...
Open.
Oh, here.
See?
Under my name, under my name.
And then I think you have to do for the next... Oh wait, oh yeah, because it's the hard one.
Okay, wait.
What colors are there?
Pink...
Oh, there's orange.
Okay, I'm orange.
I'm green.
Maybe there's turquoise.
Aren't you more like minty turquoisey?
That's okay.
I can be green.
Oh, okay.
I recently saw you kind of be more blue than mint colored.
Oh, that was a mistake.
Mistakes were made.
But it was refreshing.
I can be purple too.
Oh, you can be anything.
Can you be orange though?
Oh, maybe.
I want you to try.
Okay, I'll be kind of orange.
Wait, my hair...
If I do my hair orange, I already have the mint tips.
So I would look like cosplaying you.
No way.
Are you doing it right now?
No, it would take a long time.
Okay, okay, okay.
Alright, alright.
Let's do this.
Let's do this!
Unless anybody in the chat has one more...
One more idea for what to change in the settings.
Random map.
I wonder if it's a shitty map.
You should do a bigger map.
Too large.
Ah, location is what I meant.
The arena, should we do arena?
Large?
What's arena?
I'll do medium arena.
Arena is quite popular.
But I guess arena starts with walls.
I don't really want walls from the get-go.
Although, next one is a bit easier for us beginners.
We already have walls.
It's okay, it's okay.
Arena starts with walls, yeah.
Allow cheats?
We can give ourselves cars.
You know what?
If we end up kinda like...
Starting to lose...
Our last resort can be using cheats.
Okay.
Okay, let's do Arabia.
And...
Is medium size really okay?
It says for 4 players.
We're gonna have 3 players though.
But they're basically like 2 players.
Yeah...
I guess he'll be booming a lot.
More than us maybe.
We gotta be strong.
We'll be strong, we'll be strong, yeah.
Wait, I don't think you turned on the cheats though.
Oh!
Is it here?
Allow cheats, there we go.
Turbo mode.
What is turbo mode?
No, we don't need anything here.
You guys are setting up, stop being impatient.
Sorry, sorry, sorry, I'm scared.
I'm stalling.
No, don't be scared.
The AI is ready, I'm ready.
What about you?
Oh, I was ready.
I clicked ready earlier.
Now you're really ready.
What you gonna be?
I don't know, it's so exciting.
I love the gacha.
Gacha, gacha.
Hindustanis.
Oh, yeah.
And then we have Ethiopians.
Ethiopians.
Alrighty.
OK.
Let's take them down.
Bring it on.
Wait, I have camels.
Alright, alright.
Hard mode is probably gonna be like they're constantly gonna send small raids.
Wait, what do you mean?
OK, first thing you do, select your scout and then go auto scout.
Yeah, yeah, I just had him run.
I just had him run.
Wait, you're so far from me.
It's OK.
Maybe he'll be sandwiched between us.
It's good.
We can attack him from both sides.
I hope he attacks you instead of me.
I'm looking for stone.
I found stone.
OK.
Oh, we got turkeys.
I got turkeys.
Yeah, I have turkeys too.
I'm gonna make another villager.
Guys, I'm scared.
Me too.
But don't yell at us to do what to do.
Or at least not me.
You can yell at Chiara if she wants.
I'm just gonna play the game.
If I lose because of you, girl.
We're so over.
No, you won't.
I'm gonna build houses.
Yes, me too, me too.
And then my other guy will start mining gold.
Gold already?
I need more units.
Make sure you got food.
Are you killing the turkeys?
Yeah, they're killing the turkeys.
I got one person on each thing except gold.
But I'll get gold.
Lucky AI?
Why lucky?
Because they're being sandwiched or because we're easy targets?
I see your turkey.
Yeah, they're cute.
They have orange tips.
I refuse.
This is my first time on hard mode.
Crazy.
Wow, look at her using the CTRL key.
What are you using?
Oh, I need more wood.
CTRL is what I'm using.
She's in control.
Is this a tree?
That's a tree.
It's small, right?
It's like a little bush.
I didn't even realize I could get that.
Yeah, it's kinda weird.
Where the hell are the rest of the trees?
My scout is coming straight to you.
Really?
Be nice to him.
I'm gonna give him a rude awakening.
I'm scared.
We're currently leading in... No, we're not.
You're leading in resources.
But we're not so far from him, so, you know, he's like still... We're on the same level.
OK, we're on the same level.
Alright, I'm gonna build an outpost out here.
More trees.
I need to mark it to see your ally.
I guess I'll do a little...
Because I see the gold, I'll do a mining camp.
Here's some stone.
I wonder how much.
You know what?
Just build... Give me two more men.
It's OK!
Don't worry, don't worry.
Alright, this is my dedicated builder man.
More, more, more.
We need more villagers.
Wait, give me some turkeys.
Oh my god, he's already so far!
What do you mean?
We're allies, we're allies, so...
How do you know he's already so far?
Because he got... OK, he's not that much further, but he's leading in resources now.
On the bottom right, you can see.
On the bottom right?
It's not that bad, I guess.
How do you... Oh, show score.
Oh, you don't care?
Yakuno!
That guy's scary, Yakuno.
OK, I got men, I got men.
Alright, you start doing that.
Alright, let's build a mill.
Wait, no.
I don't need that right now.
Wait, I mean, I will.
I don't have any... What's it called around by me?
Any water.
But we're not fishing in this game.
In this map, there's probably no fish at all.
What's another dark age building?
Like mining camp and stuff?
Yeah, I have that.
Did you build that?
I have that.
I guess the mill?
Yeah.
The barracks?
Oh, did you build that?
Oh no.
Oh no, I need more wood.
OK.
Tiny water.
Lumber camp.
Oh, lumber camp!
Thank you, guys.
Let's see.
Actually, you do it here.
And then you...
Wait, no.
Lumber.
Lumber camp, right here.
Build a house.
OK,
OK.
Mill, mill, when?
Come on, wood, come on!
I'll send one more to wood.
OK.
I need more resources.
Oh!
Oh my god!
There's your guy!
I see him.
And he's gone.
Build order.
Oh my god, I haven't thought about that in a long time.
Build order?
There's a build order?
You should aim to already advance into the next age after you have 12 villagers.
I have 13 now.
I'm not ready, bruh.
OK, I'll get two more.
I'll get two more and then I'll...
Oh, I need a lot more food.
I need way more food.
Where are my turkeys at?
Maybe they're already eaten?
Mine are all eaten.
Mine are almost all eaten, yeah.
OK, time for...
AI will go futile in a few minutes.
We gotta speed up.
I need more food.
I have an AI scout!
He's a scout in my area.
Ignore him.
He's fine.
You can do that.
He can't do that.
I won't let him.
He can't.
No, he can't.
He stopped.
He stopped in front of my guys.
He's taunting you.
Yeah, he really was.
I have all three scouts in my village.
Please, can we...
Can we give me some space here?
I can stay with you.
No!
There's a tent over there.
He was just looking at me.
You guys saw that, right?
Menacingly.
OK, bye scout.
Oh!
I found a relic.
But you can... Just ignore it for now.
But remember its location.
It's right next to me.
That's your relic.
It's made for you.
It's made for me.
Just for you.
OK.
I'm...
Getting there to...
I'm like...
Almost halfway to be able to go to feudal.
Really?
Wow.
Maybe I should...
Is that a panther?
We got panthers in these woods.
He might attack you if you get too close to him.
I'm ignoring him.
More food.
OK.
I'm just gonna make more people.
One more time.
We need more food.
No choice.
Need more food production.
Faster food production.
Faster food.
We need the upgrades.
Are we not doing so badly on resources?
Not so bad.
I'm lagging.
I'm sorry.
Oh my gosh.
They're going crazy.
We're doing pretty well.
Oh, but he suddenly...
He's in the feudal.
He's in the feudal woods.
Time to panic.
We're panicking.
Should we make more?
I want to keep the food.
Oh no.
No.
I wish I had more turkey.
OK.
I guess the boar will get more.
Come on lady.
Get that turkey.
Yeah, actually, let's send him to the turkey...
to help her out.
And then...
OK.
Multiple people on turkey.
Turkey duty.
Kill him.
Go get him.
He can go back to the farms.
Don't let him die.
He's dying.
So close.
You have people dying already?
I had a villager die from a boar.
But it's OK.
My scout is not going very far.
What's the ETA of a small army attack?
Do I want to know?
No.
Don't say that.
I need to build... Should I build a barrack?
Now?
You can't, right?
Until we get to feudal?
No, I can't.
I can't.
It only costs wood.
Is he up or down?
I wonder.
I have another turkey.
I'm going to feudal!
You're going to feudal?
She's going to feudal.
I'm going to feudal!
I'm going to make another man.
Yeah, we're on to the side door.
For now.
Where's my scout?
Do I still have a scout?
Yeah, he's got to be around, right?
Mine is just in the corner.
Mine is exploring areas he's explored before.
Wait a second.
Can I get these deer?
I think he's dead.
What are you guys doing so far?
Can I get these deer?
No.
Dang it.
He's fast.
I didn't think he would be so fast.
Oh no.
Did I get my guy yet?
He's still researching.
That's why.
Here we go.
I'm at 70% almost.
I thought it would shoot.
I thought my town center would shoot at him.
Girl, help!
Help!
Wait, are you dying?
No, no!
I'm doing stupid things.
Ok, this will be fine.
How did that happen?
Oh, feudal age.
Ok.
I'm feudaling.
I just saw... I couldn't see what was going on.
Except I could see that the boar was attacking.
Wait, can you eat the boar?
Yeah.
I think they bring a good amount of meat.
It's more efficient than berries probably.
So you wanna make sure that you've got somebody.
Do you think I should try it, guys?
Should I try it?
At first you should give them loom.
You should upgrade to loom.
Otherwise, you know...
They will probably die easily from the attacks.
And you could try baiting the boar closer to your town center and stuff like that.
There's all kinds of tactics, but it's probably too complicated for a beginner.
She called me dumb, you guys.
No, no, no, no!
I mean...
You know how it is.
Ok, this will be the outskirts right here.
I still have this one berry bush.
Maybe that wasn't a jaguar.
Maybe that was a bear.
A boar.
Could be.
Yeah, right.
I don't think... Is there a jaguar on this map?
Oh, it looks like a jaguar from the front.
Yeah, you're right.
It's not a jaguar.
I think jaguars are more, you know, cat-like usually.
True.
Ok.
We have a long tail.
Alright, I'm building buildings.
I'm building buildings.
Getting the buildings in.
Alright, time to start getting some militia.
Oh yeah!
Yeah?
Yeah.
Should I too?
I should maybe too, but I'm so lacking food.
Ah, me too now.
Stop making fun of the way I say jaguar.
You know, last night... Speaking of cats, can I share this little tangent?
I was so excited.
Last night I... Where are these guys going?
Last night, my cat's movie, she's like looking out of, you know, those windows that are like doors.
So tall, tall windows.
So it goes onto the floor.
Yeah?
And I was like, oh, what is she looking at?
It was late at night, you know?
I know where the... Wait, I know where the red team is.
Oh, below us.
Ok, ok.
They're being sandwiched.
Good, good, good.
Anyway, sorry.
Your cat?
Yeah.
So, it was late in the night and Smoovie, my cat, was noticing something outside in the dark.
And she was sitting in front of the window door and loafing in front of it and looking outside.
And I saw, because it was so dark, it looked like a silhouette of something.
And I thought it was just a reflection of Smoovie.
But I looked closer and I'm like, eh?
Maybe a reflection?
I'm getting attacked!
You're panicking again.
You good?
I'm getting attacked!
Oh my god!
You're getting so muted from Discord because you're screaming.
I'm getting attacked!
Oh my god, there's a lot of them!
I can't see the action!
Did he actually come for you?
Yes!
No!
Ok, I need to prepare then.
I need to prepare because maybe he'll attack me soon too.
But he won't send two teams at once, right?
You're first.
At least you already have...
I'm in my zone!
You had some?
No, I didn't finish up making them yet!
Oh my god, there's a lot of them!
There's a whole lot of them!
Get your... maybe your villagers can help.
Or garrison them.
What does your chat say to you?
Bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing!
This is the garrison, right?
What does garrison mean?
Yeah, I think so.
I'm here too now.
Oh my gosh, there's a lot of them!
How did chat think we could handle this?
There's a lot of them, Kyo!
I'm still making more enemies, but they're very...
Oh, they don't stand a chance.
Oh my god.
Um...
Cheat, cheat, cheat, cheat!
No, no, no, no!
See, this is the point where I also usually get overwhelmed when the AI rushes at me early.
Oh, they just took out that.
Because they get me as a... what's it called?
With their archers before I can even reach them.
My guys are dead.
No!
Don't attack me, please!
Then garrison even the ones that you're currently making.
Attack, attack!
I think you can do that, right?
But the militia that you are creating, keep them inside of the barracks.
Is that a thing?
And just horde them, horde them...
I don't know, actually.
He's in Castle H!
We're so fucked!
No, we're not fucked.
No, we are fucked.
Yeah, I think we're pretty... I think it's over.
I can't make anything because I have no people making food.
I can't do anything.
Cheat, cheat!
How do I cheat?
What's a cheat?
How do we cheat?
I think you just type in something in the chat.
I think we need to... she needs to cheat a little bit, otherwise it's so over.
What's the car cheat?
Or what's a good one?
The goat is so funny or whatever that was.
What is how do you...
What is that?
How do I turn this on?
That was something, yeah.
What did I do?
Did that spawn something?
I don't think so.
Goodbye, goodbye.
What goodbye?
It's ok, just let it play.
What's playing?
Oh wait, what?
Are you dead?
Don't die!
How do you turn this on?
What?
Oh, how do...
How do you turn this on?
What did I do?
With spaces.
Oh, how do...
Why did you all send it with one word then?
Turn this on.
Huh?
Oh wait, sorry, you.
How do you...
I have a car!
They were sending...but they were sending it...
Everybody was sending it with one word.
Oh my god!
Oh my god, they are still coming after me.
They are so intense.
Ok, everybody come out.
Back to work, like nothing ever happened.
What happened?
We are ok.
Type in Alpaca Simulator.
What?
Get Ten Guide.
I seriously got Ten Guide for real.
Like everybody...
No, it sounds familiar.
I think it's real.
No, no, everybody was sending it to me with no spaces.
And I'm like, what are you talking about?
Yay, I got a car.
I'm coming over to you.
I'm gonna show you my sick ride.
Oh, you got the car!
Girl, rebuild your economy.
They are working on it.
I need food.
Ok.
Don't show off your car if you don't have...
I'm gonna do wheelies in your fields.
No, you are ruining my crops.
Oh my god, stop!
What even is this?
I'm doing donuts.
Witchery!
Sorcery!
Ok, bye.
What is this?
It stinks!
It moves too fast.
My wood is gone too.
Everything is gone.
Your car!
You are focusing too much on your car!
You need to focus.
Rebuild, rebuild.
Don't give up.
I am rebuild.
Wait, can I take this guy out?
Oh yeah baby!
All the boars!
Oh yeah baby.
Where is more wood?
This really feels like barely any wood.
Ok, good, good, good.
Wait, no, no, no.
You keep doing your thing.
Keep doing your thing girlfriend.
I only have women left.
I'm a society of hot babes.
I won't use the car much though guys.
It's only for last resort.
In fact, I'll take him over here and kill this boar.
Wait, did I lose the boar?
Where did the boar go?
I'm hungry.
I should try exploring.
I don't have a scout anymore I think.
I'm being attacked again.
Wait, no he's not.
This is not fair.
I didn't even have time to regenerate.
Who do you think you are?
Oh my god!
They are obsessed with me Chiara.
I'm obsessed with you too.
Understandable.
I wasn't even gonna use this.
Why am I so out of wood?
Where are they coming from?
OK, I wanna actually play the game.
Not enough wood.
Oh, my farm is exhausted.
OK, let's have you build...
Oh, I don't have enough wood.
No, me neither.
More wood, more wood.
I love this lady is like doing the farm but it's like on fire.
So she's like taking care of the crops while it's on fire.
Guys, I can't really sell much of anything.
You have a market already?
Yeah.
Damn.
I need a market too so that I can see you properly.
I'll send my guy over.
But I don't have a market yet.
So no point in sending him over.
I don't even have enough wood for...
Oh, because I built that guy.
I can't make shit either.
Oh, you do farm please.
I need more wood.
Oh, did my scout come visit you?
No?
No.
Maybe he did.
Oh, this guy still has...
What were you doing over there, mister?
He's a little confused.
Confused.
Nice thumbnail, right?
It's art.
It is art.
It's beautiful art.
We got people on wood.
It's a little slow.
We're slow, but it's okay.
We're doing it.
We have the same issues, girl.
I feel connected to you.
This is the real experience.
Okay, I'm coming to trade with you.
Wait, do you have a market?
No, I don't.
My priorities lie elsewhere.
Look at my camel.
He's so cute.
He's such a cutie.
It's okay.
Don't worry.
Are we gonna die?
No.
Maybe.
Is this the end of our romance?
Get a car if you think you're gonna die.
Okay.
Thank you.
I think Kiara's thumbnail is superior.
It's pretty good, yeah.
Yeah, it is pretty good.
I mean, but I didn't draw it, so really the thanks goes to the artist.
Thank you, artists.
Okay, you come over here.
We love you, artists.
We need you to build this here.
We need more mint and guava fan art, you know.
Wait, this here.
And Lainey, you take your stuff back and then we're gonna have you build the berries.
Advance to the imperial age!
Bro!
Why did anybody think that we could do this?
Yeah, what were you guys expecting?
So unrealistic!
We're not that good!
This is so funny!
Oh my gosh!
So funny, my eyes are tearing from all the fun laughter.
This is how it would be playing with chat, you know.
What do I need?
Oh, I just need a few buildings.
Haha, woods.
Haha, it fucking takes wood!
Wait, why is my thing all ugly now?
My lumber, my mill used to be so pretty and now it's ugly.
What happened?
Namaste, snake.
Let's get lumber upgrade.
Why is my Oshi not min-maxing?
I know, it's so true.
We're not, I'm trying my best.
I'm trying my best.
You got trained, I've never been trained.
It's been like a year or so.
I'm advancing.
I need house, shit.
Bro, make house.
Wait, I have bored people.
You build this.
You build mill right here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
At least I have a watchtower, that should help a little bit.
Mint-maxing.
I could use some more wood.
We need more guys on wood.
Wait, where is my board?
Oh, he's bored because he's not trading with anybody because someone...
Well, well, well, milady.
Someone was about to die and vanish from this map.
Yeah, it's very true.
Maybe she shouldn't have had a market.
Maybe she should have had more militia.
What?
I'm trying to make militia.
I'm gonna make more archers then.
They're strong.
Archers are strong.
Oh, I don't have enough wood.
Dang it.
Why do you need wood for an archer?
When you click on the lumber camp, do you have any available lumber upgrades?
How do I click on it?
Oh, there it is.
Yeah, I have to wait for more wood.
There we go.
I know, everything takes wood.
The infighting has started.
It's the stress, man.
It's the stress of dying.
Of impending doom.
Understandable, wouldn't you say?
I think so.
Let's make everybody gather here.
Let's see.
You go get some berries.
Now if I kill this boar...
Oh no!
It doesn't work!
Hit and run!
Okay, that's fine.
Need more houses.
Okay, okay.
And you build another house.
Can we even win this?
Yeah, we can.
I'm feeling optimistic.
It's also been a while since he attacked any of us.
So I wonder when is it gonna happen next.
And it will be me for sure, right?
No, I think I'm closer, so he keeps going after me.
Okay, you guys built that.
Who's my board guy?
Oh, the guy that once took trade.
He has no one to trade with.
So sad.
I'm not gonna put in cheats, guys, unless it's a desperate situation, okay?
No cheats.
We're trying to do this fair and square, unless it's desperate.
Oh, I'm getting attacked again.
Car!
Where am I getting attacked?
Oh, there he is.
Actually, hold on.
Maybe he can do it.
Maybe they can do it.
It's not that big of an army this time.
Come on, team!
It may not be a big army, but he's in castle age.
I can be castle age.
No, next age.
Next aging, whatever it is.
Are you okay?
You're dying so hard again that your Discord is muting you.
They're coming in with the rams!
With the rams?
There's nothing to ram over there, is there?
I have a place.
Hey, stop attacking my people.
I'm glad I have the car, but my car might die soon.
Oh my god!
They were really saving up.
Kiara, they were really saving up.
Kiara, they were really...
They are obsessed with me!
Oh my god!
No!
Do not!
Don't!
Get the car!
Get another car!
Get two cars!
You need them probably.
Otherwise they're going to destroy everything you have and you have to rebuild again.
I'm okay.
We're fine.
We're okay.
Yeah, we're okay.
Actually, oh my gosh, we killed the guy on the farms and it's adding like...
His decaying body is fertilizing the fields.
Did they kill these guys too?
Are you close to castling?
They're still attacking me.
Oh my gosh, get him!
Get the wall alone!
They're still attacking me.
It's okay.
Oh my gosh, they're still...
Come on, please!
Leave me alone!
Leave me alone, please!
I'm just one car!
Why is he targeting you?
I don't know!
Yeah, we need some towers.
Yeah, I'm going to go start building some.
I'm about to lose my car.
Get another one!
What's the cheat?
How do you turn this on?
This on?
Yeah, I think so.
Or this thing?
I don't know.
Did you get it?
Yeah.
But it exploded.
What?
It literally exploded.
Oh, they killed my man!
What's the noisy goat or whatever donkey?
Noisy donkey, was it?
Noisy donkey?
That one was funny.
There's just blood...
That's my stone!
I won't stand for this.
You're stealing your stone?
Yeah, but there's stone right next to my house.
Next to my village and they're taking it.
Well...
Oh gosh.
Seems like...
I think I'm in war.
I think...
I'm chilling.
Everything is cool here.
You get all the resources and I'll take them out, you know?
Oh my god.
Ok, ok, sounds good.
If he's focusing on you, I can be booming.
Yeah, you boom, you boom, you boom, you boom.
Oh my god.
I'm in castle age and I will try my best to get into imperial age as soon as possible.
You're in castle age?
Yeah, yeah.
I'm building a castle right now.
Ok, I'll stay in the dark ages.
With my car.
They're so aggressive.
Ok, retreat, retreat.
Retreat, retreat.
Aim for something better.
Come on.
I have some bored people.
Come on, bored people.
Do you have a market yet?
No, should I make one now?
Yes!
What do you think?
Build a market, ok.
Build a market.
After the castle.
Oh my god, they killed all my guys farming wood.
Please.
Again?
Stop killing my people.
We need you.
We need you up front and center.
Oh my gosh.
No, no.
Just go back.
Just go over here lady.
I'm so scared.
I need you to farm wood.
Wood!
I need wood!
Oh my god.
Wait, I forgot about the market.
Market ready, market ready.
Your market ready?
Yeah, I'm making a trade cart too right now.
Ok, I'm so glad I have this car.
I think I would have been dead three times over.
I would have been dead all the time.
Cars are amazing man.
Ok, finish building our watchtower.
Yeah, yeah.
I will need another one soon.
This thing isn't gonna do crap though.
This tower is not gonna do anything.
Cart is ready.
I see your place.
I will send cart now.
Go, go, go.
Now, now, now.
I just want to upgrade.
I need 800 gold.
Oh, I need a lot of gold.
I guess I could sell those.
But I don't know.
This doesn't do anything you guys, but it's ok.
What does that mean?
I'm gonna build a wall right here.
Peace agreement needs so can support trade.
Oh, relics have been captured!
He's building a wonder!
But there is one right here!
Why is he building a wonder?
He can...
No, nevermind.
It's not a wonder.
It's a relic timer.
No, he got all the relics!
That's what I said!
He can get a relic win.
Yeah, we need... Wait, how many years has it been?
Wait, we only have...
Wait, we only have 8 years left?
Oh no, it's counting down.
That's even worse.
That's not much time.
We have to attack his monastery, otherwise...
I haven't even made it to the castle yet!
Should I go get some rams and just go...
Wait, can you make some cards and just destroy his fucking monastery?
How do you turn this on?
And just the monastery, ok?
Just the monastery.
Ok.
But then all he has to do is build a new monastery and put the relics in there.
What is he... He's taking my whip too.
Just the monastery, everybody.
Just the monastery.
We do need to take the relics away from him, so I'm gonna...
Hey, where are you guys going?
Where are you guys... You were guys gonna come for me and then you decided against it?
I'll make one for now.
Here they go.
Oh, my one car is stuck.
Control of relics was lost!
Go!
Retreat!
Oh, this one is stuck though, so I think he should just kind of chill here.
Do whatever he wants to do, you know?
He's parked, he's parked.
Yeah, he's parked, he's parked.
Ok.
See?
We're putting boundaries.
We're not using the cars to completely...
Yeah, exactly.
We just don't want a relic win.
We need more time to make ourselves stronger.
Yes, yes, yes.
Pretty much.
They will understand.
You guys understand that, right?
Look how shitty we are.
We need more time.
We need more...
You know, they need to go easy on us.
We can't handle this.
Will this be enough?
Will that be enough?
I don't need an entrance.
I don't wanna go.
I don't wanna...
Ok.
Alright, we're getting a wall.
We're getting a wall.
Let's make...
Some of these things.
Yeah!
I know, my cars are so messy.
Why am I making them when you can just send your cars?
I don't need to make ramps for them.
No!
No, no, no.
I lost all my cars.
If we can't do it legitimately, we'll try.
Yeah, we're going for it.
Oh, there are some waters here and there, but I don't know if they're even worth it.
No, they're super tiny.
They'll be all outfished immediately.
I'm actually... Do I wanna take that over?
Who is this?
These are just regular people.
Whomst?
We sent regular people to you?
Yeah, they sent... Wait, they're taking my wood!
It's just tourists.
Let them be.
No, no, no!
But now he also keeps on sending villagers to me now because he wants to build a farm over at my place.
It's so annoying.
They're taking my wood!
How did they... Where did he get that from?
He's distracting me.
Where did they get that?
Ok, I can go to the castle age.
Wait, wait!
He asked me... He wants to join my side if I send him 500 wood, food, gold and stone.
If thou dost this thing, I shall join thy side.
What?
Wait.
How many?
How much?
No, that's silly.
That's silly.
We don't wanna win like that.
I'm going in.
I cannot believe he has the audacity.
That was too much for you.
Too much for me.
That was too much for me.
How dare you try to get Takanashi Kira to...
Betray a little bit, right?
You're just tickling him, right?
Yeah, I'm just gonna send a... you know...
I see.
It's like your cars are peeing at the townspeople.
I know.
It's just like a little warning, you know?
Like a little...
Good warning.
Keep on tickling him.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
While I am building my empire.
Actually, I think I can...
Guard duty.
Yeah, that was a warning for you, fellas.
Big warning.
Can you show us Kiara's empire?
It's beautiful, isn't it?
I'm trying.
It's not...
You have so many people.
How are you doing it so well?
I could still make more...
Your scout is just kinda chilling there, by the way.
Oh, I already see the whole map.
Oh, that's true.
Yeah, me too.
Oh, that's green.
Your scout is also kinda chilling in the top left corner of the map.
Middle left.
You're castling!
How dare these people!
How dare!
You're building walls!
Yeah, I have to.
Some of us have people who keep ambushing our society.
Kill the innocent!
They are complicit, so they are not innocent!
See?
They've been stealing your stuff too.
It's like ants.
It feels like an ant invasion.
I know!
It's horrible!
Get the fuck out of here!
Can I convert buildings?
You can with the wooloos.
They allow cheats?
Ok, but you have to understand why we allow cheats.
You have to... Look at how this is going and you will understand.
Oh wait, I forgot to... No, I said I didn't need a gate.
I'll do a gate right here.
Yeah, do you want a support car?
Oh my god!
The audacity of these people!
They are just ridiculous!
They come into my territory and they build their little...
They build... Here, actually, I'll kill you.
He's so funny.
They build their little camps.
I can't... They're shameless.
Absolutely shameless.
What did I ask?
I'm being attacked by player MintPantone?
I'm being attacked?
No, I'm shooting the red.
I'm shooting the red.
Ok, ok.
See?
My car is still here.
He's a support car.
Actually, it won't even let me attack you, so...
Oh, that's weird.
Ok.
Weird information.
Ok, so you park your car here.
It's free parking.
Yeah, it's a support car for you.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
I'll call you when I'm in trouble.
No, he does it on his own.
He's so smart.
Oh, look at him.
Yeah, those stupid villagers.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
He'll take them down.
Oops, I keep doing right click instead.
Ok, alright.
Let's get some more villagers up in here.
Lala!
You can control attack for friendly fire.
Oh, thank you.
Oh, I'm going to the last age.
Oh my god!
They set up a whole last thing to just attack me.
Ok, bye.
Did I lose some cars?
I think I did.
Sad.
Line of defense.
Life is a highway.
I wanna ride it all night long.
Yeah, they used to sing that in the feudal ages.
They did.
The more modern version that people know, that's actually a cover.
The old life is the old pathway.
Thou like to traverse it.
You have such a way with words.
Such a word with word.
Ok.
Actually, nevermind.
I have stuff on fire, but we're ok.
Oh my god!
How did they get in?
They traversed my wall!
They used the gate.
They definitely didn't go through the part that is entirely open.
Why is your tower burning?
Are you ok?
Don't worry about it.
We're ok.
Yeah, don't worry about it.
I'm not doing my best min-maxing performance.
I'm sorry guys.
Brain empty.
I'm doing a lot.
This guy is almost dead.
I am in imperial age, baby!
I'm gonna save you, my princess in...
What do you call it?
In distress.
My distressed princess.
Have they attacked you at all?
No, no.
They're only sending...
Ah, he's doing the relic thing!
Again!
Get him!
Wait, what do you mean?
Where is the relic?
If you go to his... Yeah, he's doing it again.
The audacity.
I don't think they take me seriously as a civilization.
That makes me angry.
There's nothing serious about the cars that you're using.
It seems really silly, but...
You know, what's interesting?
The Portuguese that I'm playing, they have a unique building that they can place.
It's pretty fancy.
It will automatically, once you build it, without you doing anything, it will automatically create more and more and more of your resources.
Like it just adds on to it without you doing anything.
Alright cars, roll out!
How helpful it really is, but...
I'm taking it down!
Come on cars, you can make it.
There's a bit of a traffic jam.
Oh, it costs 20 population.
Am I getting attacked?
Is this already like minus 20?
So I had 120 before?
No problem.
Wait, how am I being attacked by myself?
What?
Oh, my cars?
Maybe I should retreat?
Retreat cars, retreat!
My cars!
Autobots!
Autobots, roll out!
It took him a while to rebuild the monastery and put the relics in.
Yeah, it did.
I'm being attacked.
He made trebuchets to get rid of my tower.
Can you send your car to kill his trebuchet?
Wait, you still have a car.
Oh, I see it.
Can I?
I can't use it.
Oh, OK.
I got it.
Now he's trying to kill my camp.
Get him!
Thank you!
I got him!
The car patrol.
He did it again!
How did he do it again?
Silly, silly.
Oh, there's a whole army there!
OK.
Can I send some genuine fighters?
I mean, you're probably gonna do it on your own, but...
I haven't made any actual men.
You're just relying on machines now.
I see how it is.
Well, well, why not?
Why not?
I mean, I work smarter, not harder.
Why do I have so many people on...
Why do I have eleven people?
Come on, everybody.
What are we doing?
Oh my god, I have so many mats.
I have so much stuff.
I need to build my army!
Where am I being attacked?
Oh, I think over here.
It's OK.
What was I doing?
Oh yeah, you take this.
Wood for years.
For real!
I was just building so much wood.
Organ guns are fun, right?
Let's make some organ guns.
Let's build a university.
We're gonna start advancing.
Are you joining me soon in the Lost Imperial Age?
I need more food.
I have a lot of food.
You do?
Oh wait, I can buy it.
I guess.
I could probably also give it to you for free, no?
Oh, do that instead.
That sounds a lot better.
No!
You need to learn!
I'm learning!
My cars are parked!
They're parked!
Sell wood?
Oh yeah.
Wait, what is this?
Reduces... Oh, reduces.
Go faster.
Now buy.
Buy.
OK, soon, soon, soon.
I'll be there.
Oh my gosh, I have so much wood.
Sell.
Did I accidentally buy wood instead of sell it?
No!
You silly, silly girl.
I'm going into the Imperial Age!
I think we need to... OK, I'm gonna send my cars in.
For the relic.
Oops, he did it again.
Cars!
That one has been around for a while.
It's already 144.
I know.
We need to take care of it.
Hey, hey, hey!
What are you guys... Focus!
Focus!
They're exploding one by one.
Attack this!
Click the meat.
He's trying.
Again.
OK, there we go.
Who's healing?
No, no, no.
Kill this guy.
All my cars are about to be exploded.
Control, the relic is lost, but they have a building still.
Sorry guys, I need more cars.
OK, four more cars.
Alright, we're going in.
Guys, we're playing the game fairly, except in this part, OK?
Yeah, I noticed that.
And a few other parts.
Just small parts.
Just small, small parts.
OK, it crumbled, it crumbled, it crumbled.
Otherwise this whole stream would already be over a while ago.
Alright, retreat, retreat.
I can't leave Kiara to, you know, be all by herself.
You guys wouldn't want that.
That would be so sad.
I would be so stressed out and then I would die too.
Welcome to Imperial Age.
You finally caught up with the times.
I'm here.
I caught up.
Fortified blood.
Oh, masonry.
Girl, I'm making the best army, the biggest army you've ever seen.
And we're gonna go in there fair and square with maybe...
Oh, hey, hey, hey, cars, cars, cars.
Cars, roll out, roll out.
Tenderly, tenderly.
Oh, he's stuck.
How did you... Those overpowered cars, how do you even manage to lose them?
Do you have like a free entrance pass or how are they letting you in there anyway?
I don't know.
They're just kinda letting it happen.
Where's my other cars at?
Did they all die?
They know that you're so stubborn.
If they won't let you in, you'll destroy everything that's in front of you.
I think all my cars died, except one.
Where did they go?
It's hard on this map, right?
Because the cars are green and it's so green.
Can you... You know that scout that you have in the very corner left side of the map?
Yeah.
Tell him to kill those villagers.
I wanna see blood.
Blood!
Gosh, they move out far.
There's a lot more villagers than I thought there would be.
He can handle it.
They're turning on him.
It was worth a try.
I would've known that there's so many more.
They're still trying.
Kiara, they just eat everything.
I make the food and they don't even help.
They just take everything.
They're so evil.
It's okay.
I'm building.
I'm making.
Should I make them work faster?
Because that will...
Research...
Does that mean they create them faster?
Spies?
I think so, right?
You wanted blood, you got blood.
That's true.
We definitely got blood.
Blood, blood, more blood.
We are coming for blood too, soon.
Kill this guy?
Kill these guys?
My wall is working at least, everybody.
We're almost out of trees.
Time to move camp.
Another castle, true.
Oh my god, I have so many...
Wait, why do I have so many bored people?
You go over here, build a lumber.
Build a lumber camp.
So many bored people.
Guys, there's a lot to handle here.
Right?
That's why... See, I really like the idea of this game.
But then there's so many points that stress me out and I wish I was better at it.
That's why I had myself be trained.
It comes with practice.
I think this is good practice though, because I've only played on the easy ones.
And so now I can actually see how an AI at its strongest would work, you know what I mean?
It's kind of scary.
It's really scary.
It's not its strongest yet though.
What?
They're stronger?
Yeah, extreme I think.
And then you could still make it more difficult by changing other settings too.
I'm pretty sure...
Oh no, I'm out of stone!
Time to build camp here.
Oh, I hear cars.
Oh, I hear one car is bullying one villager.
Nevermind, he's done.
Yeah, they're trying to build stuff and I'm not letting them.
Gotta stop them from booming somehow.
But wait a second!
His resources are so much worse than ours.
Actually...
We have a chance now I would say.
Maybe, maybe.
Chat, do we have a chance?
Surely we have a chance.
Alright, I have these guys.
You can go.
We'll need more food probably.
Alright.
The cars have made a dent.
The cars have... Look at them, they're on security duty.
What the hell is that?
What is this?
Oh, siege workshop.
Gosh, they are relentless.
They just never stop.
It's rough out here, man.
I'm hurting my own villagers because I'm trying to hurt their villagers.
No!
I should just make them...
Oh my gosh.
They are so annoying.
It's time to kill them soon.
Yeah, I agree.
I'm gonna make more cars.
No, no.
I'm doing it fair.
I'm fair.
Don't make too many because otherwise the win will be just because of your cars.
Yeah, I know.
Wouldn't that be beautiful though, Kiara?
What if we had just one car on our team?
One is fine.
Or two maybe.
All gold income.
What's this one?
Upgrade your gulams.
Elite gulams.
I like elite.
Is that a new cheat code that you're learning?
No, I researched it in the castle.
The castle is telling you cheat codes now?
No!
What is this?
Economic building.
Actually, I think this is my first time getting to the imperial age in any game that I've ever played.
How is it?
Do you like it?
It's close to how we live now, isn't it?
I'm stressed.
Yeah, it's pretty close.
Fucking economy, man.
It's so bad.
So stressful.
We live in a society.
How do I get more food, Kiara?
You want more food?
I have so much.
I wish I realized how to give it to you.
They are relentless about this gold.
I won't let you have it.
I can lower my tribute fee, I think.
But you have cars.
Why do you need food?
What?
I need to make people.
Okay, okay.
Chat, teach me...
Pause.
Teach me, chat... Oh, I can't press it.
I guess you don't see this window.
Chat, teach me how to...
First, let's wait for the tribute fee to lower.
This guy... So many idols.
You know what?
You can make our own mining camp.
I've been fighting for my life out here.
I think I deserve...
I've been fighting for my life out here all day long.
Against these damn guys.
They're trying to set up mining camps.
They attack me every two seconds.
I can't stand them.
Honestly, without you, I wouldn't be able to have such a chill time building my economy.
So, I appreciate that.
Yeah, you're welcome.
Wait, what is this guy doing?
I have 51 of the organ, guys.
So, soon... A couple more.
A couple more.
Okay, I built that.
I built the building.
Okay, let's do a wonder.
I can build a wonder?
Well, a wonder wind is also kind of lame.
And before you build a wonder, I'm gonna kill that guy.
So, don't worry.
Wait, but what do you mean a wonder wind is kind of lame?
I'm sending you 1,000 food.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you.
But what if I did a wonder wind?
You're my wonder wind.
But a wonder wind...
While you are constantly sending cars to, you know...
Save yourself...
It's not right.
We have to attack him with our own hands and punch him in the face.
Okay.
We want him to die.
No mercy.
Anytime they get close, my car really gives them a run for their money.
I'm running out of gold now.
Oh no.
You need gold?
No, no, no.
I'll sell on my market.
Can't they see that I literally have a mill right here?
And yet...
They just don't... I think they just don't stop populating.
Their people are crazy.
But, you know, it's a strategy.
They continue to annoy you.
They really do continue to annoy me.
Oh my god.
It takes their attention from other things.
Like, real people would probably do that too.
Real players.
Just have people of, like, just non-stop population growth?
Yes.
Wow.
What can I take of theirs?
It's important.
Never stop your growth.
Never.
Never ever.
Don't stop.
Just grow yourself some more babies.
Oh.
I guess I'll upgrade that.
Let's see, what can we upgrade?
We got a siege.
I can do armored elephants!
Elephants?
I'm gonna make more farms.
I need more farms.
You guys think that you're gonna come and ambush me, huh?
You guys think.
What are you trying to do coming up here, huh?
I'm so, so ready.
I have 60.
Do you think that's enough chat?
60?
60 of one single unit.
I think you need 80.
I'm not gonna lie.
Wait, where am I getting attacked?
The pikeman wants to know your elephant's location.
They don't have elephants, right?
Only mint.
I made quite a few pikeman too.
They don't have.
60 is plenty.
Okay, we're rolling out, girl.
Mint, let's freaking go.
What do I contribute to this?
No need to send the cars just yet.
We might be fine.
Okay, I'll watch you, right?
Oh, but you have nothing but cars?
Wow, look at you go.
Oh my god.
What are these?
Organ guns?
Oh my god.
I guess 60 is max.
Then I might have more than 60 actually.
60 is max for like...
Okay, get over here guys.
Oh, I'm getting...
This is difficult.
Is there just a regular person?
Are they also infiltrating over here too?
Where have they not touched my land?
Don't worry, we don't need to worry about that anymore.
What is this?
Siege workshop.
Oh, there's deer here.
Oh my god!
They've been inside my walls this entire time.
You could have had them for food.
They would have given good food.
They would have, yeah.
Alright, battle has begun!
Oh it has?
Where are you?
Oh my god!
Oh my god, I'm coming with the cars.
Yeah!
I only have two of them, so you know...
You'll have to like...
It might be a little scary.
Destruction!
I'm not even using my monks.
I'm coming here!
He built the relics.
We can ignore the relics now.
Wait, they built relics?
Where?
Oh I see it, I see it down there.
Oh my god.
Take it down!
What is this?
Archery range!
Take it down!
All of it!
All of it must go!
I'm doing my part.
We're gonna be fine.
Oh they are sending one monk.
What are you gonna do with this one monk?
What do you think this one monk can do?
Nothing!
Or everything.
No!
You will not convert anything!
Where is he?
Take them down!
Wow, their place is packed.
Careful now, careful now.
Take some distance.
Yeah, distance.
They are all shooting like bombs and stuff.
So I wanna shoot my own units.
No friendly fire...
We're in!
He's so in, but he's blocking everything with buildings too.
I know, their place is dense.
Is this the strat you guys?
No, this doesn't feel unfair.
Look Kiara...
Kiara worked really hard to get all that.
And I'm also working hard to stay alive.
Are they telling you to get more cars or what?
No, they're saying this feels unfair.
Oh, no!
You guys, you saw how I would've been dead meat.
I would've been dead meat you guys, if not...
Ok, I'm back.
Welcome back.
What is here?
Oh, there's another car.
Oh, I think my cars died.
Actually, go for this one.
My cars died.
So sad.
This is the car I lent to you.
Make two more!
Two more!
Probably getting the AI on hard wasn't the best idea yet.
I don't know what you guys were thinking.
You know, we...
I said a challenge, so...
Honestly, it's fine.
No, no, no relic victory.
I just sent some guys to the monastery.
He built it like in the very outskirts now.
You think I'm not gonna get there in time?
I mean, you could... I don't think there's walls over here.
I really think you can just like walk around it.
But there's like a forest where he didn't build walls.
No, there's not.
But all the way around it... Yeah, maybe, maybe.
No, you can just walk over to it.
I guess so, but we'll have to kill some... Destroy some buildings anyway to make pressure.
Yeah, see, you have a guy already coming through to it.
A couple of them.
Fight the power.
I'll make some too.
Yeah?
Yeah.
Some what?
Some, some...
Regular things, not...
I have... Oh, elephants, elephants.
I can make elephants.
I'm coming to join the fray!
Yeah, get some elephants!
I'm joining the fight!
Yeah!
Love to see elephants on the battlefield.
Totally not traumatic for me.
No, no, no.
No, no.
I don't feel anything.
Seeing, seeing... Elephants?
No.
Doesn't activate any kind of neurons in me.
No, it doesn't.
You're OK.
I'm fine.
I love elephants.
Yeah.
Alright, we're having everybody join up here.
Wait, what is this?
Oh, this is a blacksmith.
I hear, I hear you guys in battle.
I hear it.
I hear it, I hear it.
Scary.
Hoardings?
What's a hoard?
Battle is scary.
Very scary.
Nothing fun about it.
When, when we...
Control of relics was lost!
Attack her!
OK.
Oh, we should get rid of that.
He's building there.
How long is it gonna take him to...
Give up?
Wait.
Siege tower.
Where are my elephants?
Hurry up, elephants!
I have seven elephants coming in hot.
I hope I don't accidentally bomb them.
Because they're quite thick.
Oh, I didn't know that was a copy-paste.
It's OK, guys.
Don't worry.
What was the copy-paste?
Just being like, you cheated and didn't learn anything.
Were they saying that to you?
No, but it's OK.
I think it's...
They don't mean it like that.
It's OK, guys.
He's so done for.
But I'm gonna get those.
They have a lot of stuff though.
Oh, you got the relics down.
OK.
What is this thing?
They're so distracted.
They don't know that a second army is coming in.
I wish this... Come on, elephants!
Come faster!
Be burst now.
Wait!
I just made the elephant.
Game over!
I survived,
everybody.
I wonder if we had him on one lower difficulty.
I think so, yeah.
If we would have been able to do it.
I think so, too.
He was just so aggressive to me.
I couldn't do anything.
How does this make you feel?
Does this make you feel like you wanna get better at the game so you can handle...
Perhaps even a one versus one against the AI?
No?
No, yeah.
No, I think so.
You just wanna cheat now, huh?
I do wanna get good again.
I do.
You have to train me.
You have to get good and then you train me.
But who will train me?
I once did... It was off stream, but I did like me versus...
Three... No.
No, it was 2v2.
The achievements did not progress this game because cheat codes were used.
What do you mean progress though?
I guess it doesn't count to my...
Overall count?
You did it, Kiai.
You did us, actually.
Wait.
They're giving you the military star.
Is it because of the cost?
You killed 531 units?
Girl, I had to!
I had to!
They were actually just coming after me like nothing else.
Jeez, but I still have the largest army.
Wow.
That's how often they were coming after me.
He collected so much wood and so much... Secretly!
That bastard!
Oh my gosh!
Yeah, it was our wood and our gold.
It's still not as important as I thought it was.
No, it is, especially for building many castles and stuff and walls and everything.
I think really every map is as important as the other.
I straggled in everything, guys.
Beautiful.
Oh, he did get quite a bit of gold from just having the relics.
Oh yeah, that's gonna happen.
In the monastery.
I see, I see.
Oh, look at this beautiful graph.
Finn, you are...
Even though you have all these military achievements...
I was just constantly under attack.
He would just come every couple minutes and attack me.
Yeah, it's really kind of unfair.
I don't know why he kept on going to you.
Maybe the AI kind of knows, although it would be kind of unfair.
But maybe the AI knew that you were kind of behind a little bit.
And then chooses the one who's behind.
But I feel like that would be unfair, because a normal player wouldn't know that either.
So I don't think they would program him like that.
I think I was just so close.
I think I was just super duper close to him.
He was in the middle.
I wanna watch him play.
I wanna see his...
You wanna watch him play?
I wanna see his strats.
If he's a computer, he knows the best strats.
No, no, no.
Actually, if you wanna learn, watch actual good AOE players play.
They're so fast though, you kind of have to slow down...
Yeah, 25% speed.
And they know all the hotkeys and everything, and the min-maxing and everything.
But it's really cool, and some things you can really learn from that, for sure.
Like the order.
And you can watch these beginner videos.
Like, what's the first couple things, the first couple steps that you should do.
You know, how do you min-max everything.
You can min-max it so hard.
When you start off with 3 villagers or so, 2 have to do exactly this, and 1 has to do exactly this.
And you have to bait the boars in exactly this way, in exactly this amount of time.
It has to be perfect, but...
I think what I want from this, or rather, I play this game, and then what it makes me wanna play is like...
Like a farming simulator, like Stardew Valley.
Yeah, right?
You know?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I was saying that too in the beginning.
Like, I'm enjoying it up until the point where the battle begins.
That's when I panic.
I don't mind the battle, I don't mind the pillaging, but it's like...
I think I would have to just really learn how to...
Because obviously, like with this, I just fell behind entirely.
You just gotta lower the difficulty.
This was way too high for us.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Is Civ more farming?
Like more...
Don't know.
Because people are recommending it.
Civilization might be more your thing, is what people are saying.
Have you played?
No, but like, I don't know.
If I were to get good, I would enjoy the battle.
I just need to get good.
Oh, I don't like turn-based.
What?
Turn-based?
I don't like turn-based.
You can both play the same civilization and divide...
Oh, right.
We could, but that feels a little bit complicated.
To be like, oh, you do this, you do that.
I don't know.
No, this was fine.
This was fine.
This was fun.
It was fun.
And we don't need to play too seriously.
It's like, in the end, it's about fun, right?
We don't need to be like, oh, no cheating, no cars, because...
What other cheats are there?
Oh, there's this one donkey or whatever it is that's so funny.
I wish you would've seen it.
You should try if you play again sometime.
Okay.
I'll try.
Why is he funny?
Spawns a monkey.
He says so many funny things.
He speaks?
The super donkey.
He's like a king.
I think he has a crown.
Wait, I think I remember that.
Oh, it was an alpaca, not a donkey.
Yeah.
There's a naked guy?
Wait.
I don't think I saw the naked guy.
Do you wanna try a map where we can speedrun killing the people with only cheat guys?
But you wanna do it now or another time?
Now, if we speedrun.
Now?
Okay.
Okay, speedrun with cheats.
Yeah, but I wanna see the cheats.
Yeah, you guys are gonna teach us all the cheats.
Teach us the cheats.
Cheat run, cheat run.
So we'll still... Should we just do the same map and everything?
Same, same?
Yeah, why not?
Difficulty also?
Sure.
Yeah, same difficulty and then we'll like, you know, we'll have the cheats and we'll just be...
It will be over.
Yeah, it will be over.
We'll end his suffering as quickly as possible.
Did you get the invite?
Yeah, I did.
I'm in.
Okay.
He won't get to like any... He won't get past feudal age.
He'll be just...
No advancing in this run.
None.
I'm still gonna be random though.
Okay.
Who will I be?
Oh, what color?
Green?
Yeah, I'm green.
And you're orange.
Oh, I should be orange, yeah.
Orange it is.
I think we're ready.
Okay.
What cheats are there?
What's the alpaca?
Alpaca.
Is he super strong?
Is he...
Yeah, he's pretty alright.
Oh, I'm the Mayans now.
I don't think the Mayans are in the desert.
Okay.
What do I put in?
Catzor.
What does that do?
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
Wait...
Wait, Kiara, you have to put that in.
What?
Put in Catzor.
I know that one.
You do?
It's so cute.
Wait, but...
Was it with Zep?
Yeah.
Yes.
You should put in Alpaca Simulator.
Alpaca Simulator.
Is it him?
Yeah!
Black Death?
What is that?
Does it just instantly end the game?
Move!
I don't move, you move.
Oh, there's random elephants here.
What else, guys?
What else?
Yeah, I like him.
His name is Alfred.
What else?
Alfred!
Oh, Black Death just ends the game, so don't do that one.
Ok, we don't want that.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh shit!
My resources.
Huh?
I got like 100,000 resources of everything with a cheat code.
Wait, how?
Typing in Ninja Loody.
Don't exist.
What's this?
What did I do?
Photon Man.
Ninja...
What?
Loody?
Oh, Louie.
How many...we don't even need that many, I think.
Ninja Louie.
Oh, that doesn't work.
I have a penguin!
Oh my god, he's so cute!
What penguin?
How?
What color?
What was that, guys?
What was that?
I don't remember.
Torpedo 2.
We can build anything we want now.
Oh, it was I don't exist.
I don't exist.
Look how cute he is!
Natural wonders?
Natural wonders.
He exists now, but he shouldn't be existing in this desert.
What did it do?
Is he even strong?
How many do you want to create until we go?
What did that do?
What?
Why am I getting something that I'm not seeing?
Don't torpedo.
I need more houses.
I love the monkey head.
Wait, I need more houses.
Oh, that's a naked guy!
It's not a naked guy.
He's fast!
What is he?
I'm gonna send him through the map and make him scout for me.
He has good voice lines too.
What the heck is that?
What is that?
Marco...
Did you send that?
What did I send?
There is a flying dog.
But it must have been from a cheat code.
Guys, I got the Catzor.
In fact, they are gonna go scouting for me.
What the hell?
Oh, I see the dog!
What is that?
Yeah!
And he has a red cape, so...
Is he on the other guy's side?
Oh my God!
What was the car again?
How do you turn this on?
Oh yeah.
Oh, I found red.
You did?
Where is he?
Is he close to you?
He's on the left side of the map.
Ok, I'm heading over.
Oh, this guy doesn't seem to fight.
He's just for scouting.
I'm heading over.
He advanced to the castle already!
Yeah, isn't he faster than before?
Yeah!
I mean, I know we are like busy being crooky, but like, come on!
Left side.
I kind of made a peepee with the map.
I'm sorry.
Don't look at it.
Don't look at everybody.
I'll send my small tiny baby army also over.
Imperial Age!
Wait, how is this happening?
Where is he?
He's already...
He has...He's using Jeets too!
This is unfair!
Because of...Oh, it affects him too?
No!
You can't let him!
I'm getting his ass!
I'm already attacking him!
I'm coming.
Eh?
Does that mean maybe the cars that you spawned also affected him in the previous play?
Or maybe it was specific cheat codes that we used?
I don't know.
I'm attacking a castle now.
He has a castle already?
Yeah.
Can I not advance?
Oh well.
Oh my god!
Oh my!
No!
He's so fast!
Why?
Who told us to do this cheat?
Which one?
Which one though?
The instant build.
He has instant build.
So that's why he's getting so much stuff so fast.
Was it one that you entered?
Yeah, but I didn't know it would affect him!
Type it again to turn it off.
Oh god!
It's a fucking insta build.
It's ok.
I turned it off.
What's an easy one?
No, no, no!
Attack!
Attack this one!
You!
Stupid right here!
Turn around.
There we go.
Alright.
Even just my free units are handling it.
Oh my god!
They have so many houses!
I'm leaving them alone for now.
I'm retreating.
Retreating?
For what?
Because I want you to fight too.
I'm already fighting.
It's ok.
Oh you are?
Oh my god!
They have so much!
How do they have so much already?
What the hell?
What's another cheat we can do guys?
Why can I not advance?
What the heck?
I need two Dark Age buildings.
I don't have them?
Is this not Dark Age?
What the heck?
Oh duh.
We'll do whatever.
Marco?
Wait, you guys are telling me stuff, but I don't know what you guys are...
I already tried telling you.
Marco?
Polo?
I don't remember that.
I don't know what it does though.
Map reveal?
I tried it though.
I see the flying jaguar!
The dog?
Yeah!
He went wolf when I clicked on him.
Do I have to do Marco Polo?
Marco Polo.
It doesn't work.
Is that you?
Oh that's you!
Hi!
It doesn't work you guys.
You guys can see it, it's not revealing.
Type it Marco Polo.
It doesn't work.
Wait, are you here?
Maybe you have... yeah.
I'm here.
What's up?
Oh I see you!
Wait, who is this guy?
Photon Man!
The cat is flying or the dog is flying again.
What is he doing?
Is that a scout?
Oh he has two!
We gave him a couple.
Wait, there is some stuff over here.
There is like a monastery and stuff.
Ok, ok, I'm coming, I'm coming.
How do you do the Photon Man?
Just type in Photon Man.
Hold on...
Space in between.
There is a Photon Man.
Look at him go!
I'm advancing.
You're advancing!
Yeah.
Who is attacking?
Oh they are making elephants!
They are making elephants.
I don't know.
Playing like partially serious and then partially with cheat codes is funnier than just with cheat codes.
Yeah, I agree.
Yeah, because it's kind of just like we are just going in and exploding stuff.
Maybe as an 11 year old or so this would have been fun.
But I like seeing what the cheat codes are at least.
Yeah, that's for sure.
I got a penguin.
You wanna see him?
I'm gonna bring him over.
I already saw him before!
He's coming!
He's so cute!
But he's not meant to be in the desert.
Poor guy.
I know!
This guy!
Why do you exist here?
What kind of mods are in for this game?
Torpedo 8.
What is that?
I'm scared.
Is that all he has?
Those few more houses?
Is that it?
I don't know.
Seems like...
Do not use torpedo.
Okay.
What?
What did you... Did you put it?
Desert penguin.
I think I did.
Let's see.
Two dark ages smashing one imperial age.
I'm in the feudal age.
Excuse you, I'm in the feudal age.
Thank you very much.
I literally cannot advance to anything.
This is weird.
Star Wars mods?
Furious the monkey boy.
Well...
What did that do?
Monkey!
Bring him over!
Before this guy gives up, because it must be soon.
Soon, right?
I feel...
What's the naked man?
Why is he not giving up yet?
Maybe there is somewhere a castle hidden.
I see a relic.
Where are you?
I don't see you.
I'm looking at the edge of the map to see if he has anything.
No, I don't see your units anymore.
Did they die?
I only got my troopers left, I think.
Oh, I see you.
Trooper, trooper.
I love the monkey.
Maybe one of our cheat codes made it so that he won't give up.
There he is!
Oh my god, he's fast!
That's a good idea.
He took it out of his vocabulary.
Is that my guy or is that your guy?
It's my guy.
He can't attack though, so he's like the perfect scouting guy.
Yeah, I wish there was an auto-scout for him.
Alright, last building.
Hello?
I'm gonna build right here.
We killed his last building.
No, there's a little bit more.
Right here.
Oh really?
Right where?
Maybe he's confused.
I think the AI is like, what are you...
How did you do this?
I'm gonna have Naked Man scout the whole map.
Yeah, please, find something.
What are we missing?
I would really like to see that.
There he goes.
Make your man go find it.
Go, go!
Oh, the lion was attacking him.
I'm in your village.
Oh, goat found.
It's yours, but it's mine now.
No!
Find the enemy, not the goat.
What the heck is the dog?
I have no idea where it is.
Maybe the game is bugged.
I think the game is bugged.
Oh wait, there it is!
Ah, there it is!
It takes a while.
OK, OK.
Look at your scores.
My score...
You are such a winner.
It's because we both cheated to get all the resources.
We are the best!
100,000 of everything, please.
How did he get 52,000 food so fast?
So fast.
In the graph, I think I can see where we gave him the ability to insta-build.
Oh my gosh, he was just like, hello.
He probably was just like, how do I have this power?
Yeah, he was building farms like crazy.
Good for him.
We gave him a little bit of joy before we took everything away from him.
Yeah, look at him.
He spedrunned the feudal age, the castle age, the imperial age.
That's insane.
Dang, I thought I explored a lot of the map, but that guy was crazy.
Oh my gosh.
Good stuff, good stuff.
GG!
GG, man.
I'm glad we are playing stuff together.
We should do more often.
It doesn't have to be this game, you know, but I want to play more stuff with you.
Yeah.
Wait, there was another game that you wanted to do before we suggested this.
I don't remember, because you were just like, are you free next week?
I want to play blah blah blah.
And I was like, yeah!
And then we got busy, and then we were like, wait, it's the vampires, yeah!
I don't remember, what could it have been?
I don't remember either.
There was something.
I'm gonna look at our DMs.
Chained together.
Oh god.
Have you played with someone yet, by now?
No.
Still not?
I'm also still a chained virgin.
We can lose that together.
Maybe we should.
But you know what would be a requirement?
What?
Fan art of us naked chained together.
Wait, have you played the Sisyphus game?
The one with the big stone ball?
Yeah, okay, so play that, and then we can play chained together.
Why?
Why is that a requirement?
Why do I need to be tortured?
Because we're gonna then be tortured together.
And we'll be on the same level, you know, of our mental state.
If anything, I should have played it when it was the flavor of the month in holo.
It's too late.
No, don't play it.
Don't do it.
It's okay.
My pumpnails are drawing themselves.
It's like I'm using cheat codes.
What would the cheat code be?
What would the name be?
What's our couple name?
I see people say Mintory, but...
Mintory?
Mintory Spicy Time is the cheat code.
Mintory Spicy Time.
Yeah, I wanna play more with you in any game we'll do, you know?
Yeah, okay.
It's so nice to be with you.
I know, I like playing with you.
Guys, those were for me only.
No one self-insert.
Yeah, they're for you.
Normally, only my cats get these kisses and red superchats, but that's different.
What?
How are you giving your cats red superchats?
No, no, no.
When I get red superchats, I'm like, thank you for the red superchats.
KFP getting real fan service.
Yeah, I started doing that like a long time ago and I was like super embarrassed about it in the beginning.
But nowadays it's just so normal.
Chicken.
Chicken?
Yeah.
I'm gonna eat you.
Chicken for dinner.
Yeah.
Why not chicken dinner?
We are the winners!
One day we'll get a legitimate no cheat win, but today is not one of those days.
I still think though it was still valuable to see how the AI works.
Yes, and from my POV, it was funny every time you zoomed in with the cars to get the relic thing down.
We had to do it, we had to do it.
For the sake of our enjoyment too.
And we didn't overdo it.
We could have totally like raided him with those cars completely.
I know, right?
I stayed outside.
In fact, when they started attacking the other buildings, I was like no, no, no, let's go.
Well, I'll practice a bit more so I can carry you better.
Okay.
Carry me, princess carry me.
No, you gotta play more too, because that was like literally the only stream in the longest time ever that I kind of like...
And like just was able to chill while watching.
So please play more Age of Empires, especially because you don't have to wait like a whole week to get perms each time.
Oh, true.
Can you play like tomorrow?
I could play, I already have my schedule, but I mean...
Fuck it!
What are you doing for Valentine's Day?
Are you perhaps turning the dress around so that it's on your backside or...
No, I have some other things to show off.
Mmm...
Well, well, well...
You know what you should do?
What?
You should do a...
Mint chocolate...
Making hand cam stream.
Oh.
Why didn't you... Why didn't you suggest... I already have... Well, I'm still in the process of making everything, but...
Why did I not suggest you a Valentine's Day stream idea earlier?
Yeah, why didn't you give me context now?
I didn't know you were struggling.
I didn't know you didn't have an idea.
You seem like, you know, you come up with ideas quite easily on your own.
Yeah, I haven't.
Well, I actually had an idea and I had to scrap it this week, like two days ago, so I quickly scrambled to come up with another idea.
So I've been making that.
Oh, I'm curious.
I'm looking forward to it.
Whatever you do, but also play AoE, please.
Okay.
I can also off-stream, you know.
Oh, no, I don't care for that.
Oh, never mind.
I will never touch it again off-stream.
No, it's gonna be... It's gonna be a proper stream, because I don't... You wouldn't even, like...
Oh, you mean... Oh, you would practice.
I thought you meant you would stream privately to me on Discord.
Oh, do you want me to do that?
No, no, no, no, no, this is not the same.
It's different.
Okay.
But yeah, you could play off-stream if you wanna.
If you feel it.
If you're feeling it.
I did a couple times.
I just feel like, if I'm gonna, like, play a game, I'm gonna stream it.
But today, I was practicing before the stream, but, you know, normally...
I know, you're so diligent.
Just a little.
I didn't wanna, you know, be absolutely clueless when playing with you.
Are you... Okay, wait.
Who trained you before?
It's somebody who is, like, a caster for, like, professional Age of Empire matches.
She, like... Before she focused on casting, she was more of a, like, focused professional player herself.
Her name is Ellie.
Ellie4k.
I looked for all of the AoE players that I could find, and I, like, found this cute chick, and I even met her in person.
What?
Oh my god.
Ellie4k, don't watch this stream, okay?
She would be so disappointed.
I don't know if she's still active, actually.
We haven't talked in a long time, and I don't know what she's up to right now.
But she's really sweet, and she teaches really well, but then she always makes an alarm when I have an idle villager.
She's like, we will, we won't, we won't, we won't, we won't.
And I'm like, aah!
She was, like, hardcore.
It's like a boot camp.
Yeah, yeah.
It sounds pretty intense.
I should have done that.
We will, we will, we... Actually, yeah.
No!
Don't you dare.
I can't hear it anymore.
Recently, she's still streaming?
Okay, but I think probably not, like, every day, right?
But, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, we're gonna become professionals.
You and me.
Not by ourselves.
That's the dream I had a year ago, and, I mean, you know...
I feel like I would play it more often, more consistently, if I didn't have to ask what params each freaking time.
Oh, yeah.
No, I get that.
Because having to plan so far in advance is a bit rough.
I know, we actually... I will schedule a stream for next week, I think I will.
Oh my gosh, everybody excited for more.
Whether you join me or not is your choice.
But maybe it's good to, like, learn a bit more alone again before we do another collab.
Yeah.
On this game.
Get our individual skills up.
I still wanna play with Chat, too.
Even though they'll obliterate me.
Be easy on her, Chat.
Otherwise, what's there to learn?
Like, give her... Don't kill her immediately.
Give her some time to build up.
What are they saying?
They're saying... No mercy.
No!
Maybe you should play with my Chat.
Yeah, KFP, will you be nice to me?
I think they will.
They will, they will.
They learn from me to, like, have restraint.
I taught them to be nice in these situations.
I'll turn on cheats only for me.
If they get too out of line, they get the car.
Yeah.
Come on, Chat.
You gotta be nice, especially to guests.
Wait, are they not...
You gotta make a good impression.
KFP, are you not being very kind?
Okay, somebody said some mercy, but a lot of them say no mercy.
But they'll give you mercy, right?
I didn't ask about that.
Would you guys give me mercy?
Yes, you would.
They might say no mercy, but they don't mean it.
Oh, they're putting the polite emotes.
They're so polite.
They're so considerate.
Only Wawa.
Oh, yes?
Oh, some of them are saying yeah?
I'm so flattered.
What's wrong with you guys?
Hey, Wisps, what's wrong with you?
Yeah, Wisps, come on.
At least 50% of you guys gotta say yes.
We'll be merciful.
No, but they also don't mean it.
They're tsundere.
No, they mean it.
Because you're so teasable.
No!
It's that Toy Story meme.
I'm dropping the idea of playing with them now.
I don't wanna play with you anymore.
There it goes.
Your chance to play AoE with her.
That's how easy it is.
Gone.
It's gone.
You should've said yes just to lead her on and then obliterate her.
That's worse.
That's a betrayal.
But then at least they would've gotten to play with you.
Oh, that's true.
I'm telling you the strats, chat.
I'm telling you.
Lead her on.
No!
Don't lead me on!
Discord cut you out when you're getting squeaky.
Sorry.
Don't lead me on!
Can I lead you on?
You can lead me anywhere, baby.
Alright, I'm gonna go cook dinner now.
What are you gonna do?
I'm also gonna go... Actually, I'm gonna work on my Valentine's livestream.
I have to work on some stuff too tomorrow.
Stay to play.
Oh yeah, stay to play!
I saw the announcement and I saw it was apparently pretty long too.
And I was wondering, maybe I'll squeeze a watch along.
Long?
It's usually like an hour, 45 minutes, right?
Yeah.
Yeah, so it's like... Maybe good?
What could there be?
What could they announce?
You think so?
Is that realistic?
It's not just your innocent heart?
No, I think it's really actually...
People are wanting the old Bloodborne too.
That seems unrealistic apparently.
That's copium.
That's been copium for like the past however long.
Ah, Death Stranding 2 news.
Yeah, maybe some updates.
Have you played Death Stranding before?
I have.
I didn't finish it, but I have played it.
I was also... I watched Pekora's full playthrough of it years ago.
Before I joined Holo.
It was like my corona therapy.
So now, I don't know.
Something about it, I just want to play it.
So I might play it sometime in 2025.
You should.
It's really...
Well, there's like stressful parts, but part of it's so relaxing too.
There's just something so nice about this game.
Walking, yeah.
Yeah, hell yeah.
But there's a lot of copyrighted songs in it, so...
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
Be careful.
I'll figure it out.
Okay, so that's where we're at.
Thank you for playing with me.
We'll play again soon.
Okay.
Something.
Whatever.
It doesn't have to be this, but anything.
Okay.
Have a good day, milady.
You have delicious dinner.
Send me picture.
Oh, okay.
Your cooking is so good.
Oh, thank you.
You haven't tried it yet.
Maybe it's just the visuals that are good, not the...
Not the taste, but...
I hope the taste is good, so you're eating good food.
It depends.
Sometimes it's good, sometimes it's mid, but...
I will cook the best thing for you.
If you ever come here.
Come to Wawa Town.
Come to Flavor Town.
KFP Flavor Town!
Let's go to Flavor Town!
I'm going to Flavor Town now.
In German you say Auf Wiedersehen.
How do you say goodbye in German?
The LARPer.
I'm not LARPer!
Okay, Auf Wiedersehen, Minto.
Auf Wiedersehen.
So cute.
Thank you!
Goodbye!
Wait, are you going to talk to each other?
No, are you?
I was just going to say bye to them.
Okay, I'll say one thing.
I'll give them one small tangent.
Okay.
Are we going to see each other again?
After this?
Do you want to?
No, we don't have to.
I mean...
We could!
Wait for me!
Okay, I'll wait for you.
Bye bye!
Okay, we just muted each other.
Anyways guys, thank you for...
Oh my gosh, I didn't expect the hard to be so hard.
That guy was crazy!
That guy was...
He kept attacking me every two seconds!
I feel bad that I kind of just got lost in the sauce after the initial attack.
And then it was hard for me to feel like I could get back on my feet.
But he kept killing all my people!
It's so crazy!
Steal his strats.
I know!
Holy moly!
And it gets even more difficult!
Thank you guys for all the donos and all the superchats!
You two are always so cute together.
I have to pee so bad.
So I'm going to say goodbye to you guys tomorrow.
I'm not streaming, but I will be doing...
Well, I am streaming now.
I was not supposed to be streaming.
Rather, is what I should have said.
But I will be doing a State of Play watch along.
Because I must know about Metal Gear.
Or anything else.
I'm excited to see.
Anyway!
Thank you guys!
Bye bye!
Thank you!